The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Yeah.
Back for round two.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're here with Randall Park.
Wait,
none.
Eddie Wong,
he's stuck in traffic
coming over to Panga.
Probably Dodge and hippies.
You ever take that ride over to Panga?
Oh yeah.
Pass by those fucking
weird organic people.
I pass by a guy with a sign.
A lot of,
a lot of hemp.
I know a lot of beads.
Let a dirty feet a pass by a guy who
had a sign that said Vegan Gardner.
Like what does that mean?
Like what?
No,
it wasn't Vegan Gardener.
It was Vegan landscaping.
That's what it was.
I was like,
what the fuck does that even mean?
I just wanted to hit him.
Just want to fucking have
bears chase him or something.
Son of a bitch ran a park.
Ladies and gentleman happened and yeah.
Good to see you brother.
Good to see you,
man.
Thanks for coming on here.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
sure.
You are in the middle of the,
one of the most controversial
movies in the history of the world.
Yeah.
You are.
You play?
I play Kim Jong owner.
Yeah,
in the interview,
which is fucking crazy,
man.
I didn't think it was crazy when I
signed on I realized it was crazy.
You know,
in the midst of all that,
what is the verdict?
Because they say that it's not,
it's not North Korea.
Someone was saying it
was an insider at Sony.
They had it.
They had it narrowed down
to a woman who hacked it.
Right.
That you know,
I don't know.
Cause after they came out with that,
the FBI came out and said,
no,
it is North Korea.
We have a lot of information that we
haven't released but it is trust us.
But then you know the,
the private kind of security experts
still think it's not North Korea.
I would almost always go with private
security experts over the FBI.
Almost always I am.
I kind of feel like most
people now what also,
which is kind of sad,
that's sad for the FBI,
but I think most people
are questioning it.
W W would you be willing to go
over there ever one I ever do.
You mean like,
do you mean North Korea specifically?
Do you mean Oh yes,
very specific.
No,
not go over there.
I would never go with it.
Especially if you went over there
under the guidance of Dennis Rodman.
No,
no.
I,
I would say I wouldn't go near Dennis Rod
in America.
I would not go near him,
but I would not go near
North Korea at all.
I mean,
if the regime topples and changes and uh,
you know,
I don't know 20 years from now,
what's the likelihood of that though?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think it's fine.
I think it's possible,
but in our lifetimes I think,
but uh,
yeah,
that's the only way I'd,
well,
we were talking
about this before the
podcast started there.
They exchange flashdrives yeah.
Back and forth to each other.
Yeah.
Like in the eye,
a huge part of
the underground economy there is,
is basically these flash drives with,
with South Korean TV shows,
movies,
American movies,
you know,
just glimpses into the outside world
that they're not supposed to see.
It's a huge underground market.
So I think the people there,
especially the younger people
that they know what's going on,
you know,
and if they get caught,
not only they fucked.
Yeah.
Well this is what I read and
I don't know how it is now.
It might be even worse now for all I know.
But yeah,
if they get caught,
they go to a labor camp for,
I don't know how long that,
it's like a three generational thing.
There they are,
kids go to a labor camp there
and their parents will go.
Like the whole family ends up
being punished for their action,
which is wild.
It's insane.
Yeah.
And when,
when we hear about like
dictatorships like that,
we always think of it like if that's
from like the forties like you know,
you think of it as he is,
it is from the forties that's a thing.
And it just has not changed over there.
Yeah.
I just wonder what it would take for
something like that to be toppled.
And we were also talking before the
podcast started about his uncle,
but his uncle apparently was
planning some sort of a coup,
so yeah.
Killed his uncle.
Killed his uncle's son.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
one thing that happened when our,
when our movie was about to come
out there was like a some expert on,
on North Korea who said
that it's important that the
elite in Pyongyang see this
movie,
especially the people in the,
the,
you know,
the government and it
working it because it's so,
it's so they're on such shaky ground
right now that for them to see something
like this could like really help in
getting something to happen over there.
This is what Sony,
you were saying?
No,
no.
This was like a,
an expert on it.
Like some professor or
something on North Korea,
which I thought was interesting.
But yeah,
I,
that kind of blew my
mind when he said that.
Wow,
that's great.
Imagine if it did.
Imagine if that was the catalyst.
If hours are ridiculous comedy,
Seth Rogan,
James Franco movie catalyst
for overthrowing the last
great communist dictator.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean school communist dictatorship.
That's crazy.
I mean it's all,
you know,
as so much of it is,
is,
is this kind of deification you know,
of him and,
uh,
all of this stuff,
you know,
our movie,
but not just that,
even just glimpses into the outside world.
It just chips away at that,
you know,
and he becomes who he is,
to these people and to
other people and you know,
in the government and,
and,
and that does not help their cause,
you know,
or the government or Kim
Jong Un's cause you know,
what is the Dennis Rodman thing?
What's,
did you research him at
all when you did this?
I did,
yeah.
I mean,
Kim Jong Moon include an his father
Kim Jong Il when he was alive.
Huge NBA fans.
He was a huge basket fall ball fan.
He was like a loved Michael Jordan.
And there's a story of,
of Kim Jong who,
and supposedly he was a,
when he was a student,
he went to like an international
school in Switzerland.
And uh,
there are accounts of
him from other students.
He just sit in class all day and draw
doodle pictures of Michael Jordan.
Like,
literally in this class.
So like he was obsessed with
basketball and in that era,
and I think,
you know,
that bowls team was
running things at the time,
like rotten just to,
he was a huge rod and fan.
Wow.
Yeah.
Crazy.
It's so crazy.
See Rodman over there hanging
out with them as so surreal.
So did you see that at
that press conference?
No,
there's a video of like a press conference
where he's basically sitting there
with,
with the other play at some other players
who went with him on this trip and
he's clearly drunk
and he's basically justifying his,
you know,
his actions by going over there and,
and you know,
becoming friends with this guy and
he's like drunk and this is a press
conference from Korea or from America,
I think it was in Korea that they shot
that they shot it and you could see the
players behind him and they
just look super uncomfortable
going around like,
well,
how could you not be super
uncomfortable first of all,
hanging out with Dennis Rodman
and make you super uncomfortable.
Dennis Rodman calling a press conference.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
Yeah.
Is it the top one or the,
yeah,
that top one.
[inaudible] worth,
man,
this is la.
The traffic is insane.
Also fucking,
I'm an idiot that lost my car
in a fucking parking garage.
Did you,
you meant I was running up and down.
Were you like along third street?
Like one of those garages like the
prominent and they got three garages that
look the same and I was
running up and down.
I'm like,
where the fuck is my car?
It was right here and then they were like,
you know,
there's another parking garage.
My bad dude.
No worries man.
We,
we kicked things off.
Randall were good.
Just we had to cover the interview anyway.
We had to go over all the crazy
shit that he's been going through.
The artist formerly known as Kim Jong Un.
Did you at any point in time
feel like you fucked up now man,
you know,
no,
this is the thing.
I wasn't like scared for my
life or anything like that.
This is the thing.
There were enough
people like you,
friends,
family,
people who were genuinely scared for
my life that it got me thinking like,
should I be scared for my life?
Well you had secret service.
We had guards at the house.
Yeah.
Sony provided US guards.
If her mom,
it's like a couple of weeks,
what's the fuck Sony.
And at first at first I was like,
we don't need guards series,
so we don't need guards.
They're like,
let us just give you some
guards just for peace of mind.
I was like,
all right,
all right.
And then a one and then one
day they were just gone.
Like a few weeks later they're gone.
And I was thinking,
oh my God,
we're the guards.
I need pick guards.
You know,
like I was just so,
you know,
I felt so protected by them when I did.
It wouldn't have otherwise,
you know,
I just got used to and then my
friends being so concerned for me,
it just Kinda got me paranoid.
Yeah.
Did anyone contact you?
Did you get any threats or anybody?
No.
No one on Twitter,
like pretended to be from North Korea.
And fucked with you.
We should have done a tool.
I,
you know,
would get like spam mail,
like I always get and I would
think twice if I fee like,
wait a minute,
is this like regular spam
or is this like hacking?
So my email destroy my life spam,
you know?
And uh,
but I,
you know,
I didn't know.
I would never have,
I just kind of deleted it.
Like I always do it.
Yeah.
You're always yearning
that I was paranoid.
Yeah.
Most likely.
But I,
I,
you know,
I got paranoid.
I got paranoid after awhile and then the
movie came out and like we were talking
about earlier,
it just all died out.
The dust settled really quickly.
It was like crazy.
It was like the biggest news
and then all of a sudden,
I don't know,
it seems like things just die quick
today because there's so much new scandal
coming down every day.
There's,
there's always something new,
nutty Dick pics,
sex scandals,
something horrible happens,
you know,
isis cut somebody's head off something,
there's always some kind
of getting another one.
Yeah.
One year.
Things that used to happen in
five years happened in one year.
Now it happened in a day.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's kind of insane.
Things are accelerating for sure.
Even when I travel,
every city I go to,
there's a pocket of every
city that looks the same.
Like that same arts district is in
every fucking city with the same stores,
the same kids,
the same clothes,
and by contrast,
the same apple bees,
the same Walmart,
the same target them.
If you're in a target anywhere in America,
you feel like you're in the same file.
Yeah.
How the fuck did you go from
being a chef to being on a sitcom?
What the hell is going on,
man?
How did you run this man?
Dude,
I,
we,
I guess we kind of ran the table and
fucking definitely we were for the cycle.
You were a ted talk.
I mean,
fuck yeah.
That's when I met you deal for this
show was cut the day I met you.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
You were part of this Joe.
That's a part of this.
I feel responsible.
You're part of Asian history.
You are.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you Joe.
So how did it go down?
Well,
what happened was I was at Ted and then
there was this producer in Melvin Maher
who my boy Jay gave the book to.
So he read the book and
he was like looking these,
you
know,
stats and demographics,
they send those things in the studio
like pay attention to the Asian market.
They got fucking money now.
You know what I mean?
People were buying fucking soy products.
So he got one of those things that was
a directive or or some study saying,
look there's a lot of Asian viewers,
you know,
we should make some content for this.
The book landed on his table within
like the similar amount of time I was in
Long Beach.
I was doing the show at you
and he met me that night.
Wow,
that's incredible.
That's incredible.
And you got in trouble for doing the show,
right?
Cause you left Ted and they
get pissed at you for yeah,
they were mad because I did,
you know,
did the number one podcast in the world,
Joe Rogan and then I also did DVD asa.
They weren't too happy about that and I
went to take the meeting with Melvin and
they were like,
you should be here politicking with
these ted people suck in this Scientology
Dick [inaudible] they have like no,
no,
no Scientology deals.
Was it that that they have like in a
like a specific thing plan for you or are
they just wanted you to hang out?
No,
I had already given my talk
and then it was like dude we,
we'd looked like slow children.
They had us with signs and like neck
lanyards with your photo and like speaker
and then these people would be like donor
and we were supposed to like show more
love to the donors and oh one of those.
Yeah.
I was like this is weird.
It was the beginning of my understanding,
my,
my journey of trying to
understand what we're,
ted has gone like where it's still what
it started out as and what it is now and
you re re very illuminating.
Yeah,
it was cool cause after me and
Sarah Silverman kind of shit on it,
there's been lots of people
that come out being like,
Yo they fucked with my speech.
They told me to say this,
they took this down.
And did you find that during your speech
where they like oh in your hands in it
or yeah,
they definitely tried to edit it.
I mean it's everywhere.
The last few years I've started to realize
everywhere you go besides like pretty
much vice I guess is they,
they just,
they parked,
they tried to put the Dick in it.
Here you go ma'am.
Come here,
come here.
You want to get rich too.
There's only one way that donor day,
well they would make you
stay with somebody else too.
They made you stay in a room.
Yeah,
it was weird.
We were like adults and they had us
rooming and I was rooming with this other
guy who was super nervous about
his speech and I was just like,
this is bugged,
bugged out.
You gave me a box of kind bars and I'm
supposed to be cool with this and then
they get mad when you
go off to do other shit.
It's just a very,
very bizarre,
bizarre,
yeah.
You should sign up to be
a ted speaker one year,
just so you could like do the expo,
say not interested
too much as it is highly overexposed.
So fresh off the boat.
When does it start,
Erin?
February 4th.
It's a CBS,
ABC,
ABC.
Beautiful.
February 4th.
And is everything in the can already?
You guys done?
Are you filming right now?
Yeah,
we're done.
We're done shooting.
How many soldiers do?
13.
So they decided to film
13 and then air these,
they did a pilot.
They liked it and then they
just shot 13 or 12 more.
Yeah.
That's nice.
That was nice.
Um,
if they pick up what they call the back
nine and to give you a full order of 22.
When do you,
uh,
when do you know about all that?
I think may and we find out in May.
Yeah.
I don't know if we're going into the bay.
I think it'll be just a sec.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's cool.
So what's that experience been like?
Men,
Randall,
you go first.
I've been talking about it too.
It's Randall.
Well,
I mean also the eldest Asian goes first.
I that's right.
Respect.
Uh,
you know,
for me it was,
it was fun.
It was a,
you know,
there was a lot of challenges.
I,
I was,
you know,
I've been kind of
the middle man,
I feel like in a lot of the situation.
So I like talking to the producers,
talking to the other actors,
talking to Eddie and like,
you know,
trying to kind of navigate everything and,
and,
and hearing out their
issues and their problems.
And so I don't know that,
that,
I think with any TV show,
they're always like
politics and issues and,
and,
but when you have one that's specifically
based on a memoir of a real life
person,
you know,
there,
there's a lot of kind of bumps in the
road and a lot of things to work out.
And we definitely had those,
uh,
those issues.
But with that being said,
I mean,
I had a great time.
The cast has been great.
The,
you know,
the crew.
I had fun,
I had fun and uh,
I think it's like a,
it's a good show,
you know,
it's,
and it's a groundbreaking show
like in terms of just Asians on TV.
Well Margaret shows the first she had
that show on you can girls 20 years ago.
Yeah,
I was around back then.
I remember it.
I was friends with Margaret and the whole,
when it went down it was,
it was weird.
It was telling me you got to lose weight,
you got to do this just different.
You can have a fat Asian on TV or they
mean like her stories about her pretty
fucking crazy.
He's bad.
They had like an Asian consultant
or something on that show.
Like basically telling
them how to be Asian,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean we had those weird ass
accent coach too is too though.
It was super cool.
Super Cool Dude.
But there was a dude that
was literally like Randall,
your accent,
like checking on the accents and shit.
Yeah.
And hit that too.
That I,
yeah,
super cool guy,
friend of mine even.
But it was like it,
it definitely got me in
my head for that pilot.
So after once we got into the series,
I was like,
no,
I'm going to learn this.
What were the accent?
We try to learn Chinese accent.
It was
like a supposed to be a
mandarin Taiwanese accent.
But what I feel like there isn't one,
there isn't anyone locally
in their own fucked up.
That's what I learned.
It's like there is,
cause I went to so many
people to get like coaching,
you know,
like to get specifically
experts are actors who could
really do it because there
were no dialect coaches who could do it.
But they all had different approaches
and I was like,
there is not one way to do an accent.
Yeah.
It's basically a cottage industry for
Asian people to just g off and be like,
oh no,
no,
I know this thing.
Let me tell you.
Yeah,
it's flied lice.
[inaudible] House.
And I know,
no,
it's not always.
So they're just running the
game and the white people like,
Oh gee,
okay,
okay.
He's religious.
He understands.
Yeah,
we have an Asian accent consultant.
They hired this guy,
he's like an actress or actor and they,
he was like,
I got hired to consult on the
accent because I'm Taiwanese.
And it was like,
Yo,
this is so book.
What are they trying to do with you?
They try to fuck with your
accent because you have a no,
no,
no.
I just do voiceover,
do voiceover and give people a hard time.
That's pretty much my job on the show.
So you don't act on the show?
No,
I'm just,
I'm the voice.
Oh,
so someone play you?
Yeah,
there's a 12 year old kid
who was a really cool kid.
Wow.
So it's Sorta like that Chris rock show.
Everybody hates Chris.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Oh see I was under the
impression that you were acting.
I was confused.
But like voice.
Voice.
Right.
And who do you play?
I play the Dat.
You play his dad.
That's a weird relationship.
It's weird.
It's funny cause my mom on the
show is the same age as me now.
Oh.
But super cool rent like,
you know,
the actors on the show were incredible.
Like the casting on the show I
think is my favorite part of it.
Yeah.
I'm not just saying it
because home is here.
Like we really get along.
We hang out,
we eat Jamaican beef patties.
That's what we did worry that that 12
year old kid is going to be like that two
and a half men kid just fucking get crazy.
Yes,
yes,
absolutely.
He already gets crazy.
But I love the kid.
He's a great kid.
He's like amazing.
But he's a real kid.
He's not like a,
an actor.
He,
you know,
he didn't have hardly any experience
going in and that's part of the reason why
we loved him so much.
He was just raw,
you know,
Brooklyn,
Chinese kid that went to a cold acting
at casting and then we saw his tape and I
remember watching,
did you get to see his audition?
Uh,
I saw,
I mean,
I was there for some of the early ones,
but I didn't see the original,
his audition is so funny.
They're like telling him to say things
and he's swinging at the camera with his
arm.
He's looking in the wrong direction
and he just doesn't give a fuck.
And I saw the tables like
we have to cast this kid.
Just personality and just personality.
He couldn't be bothered
and not be bothered.
And even when we sh,
I mean Randall may hate us at times just
because the kid will be bouncing off
the walls.
Like we basically just captured
this real kid on camera.
Cool.
Start,
stop.
Yeah.
But the other kids,
like they were all polished actors,
you know,
with clean line reads,
like,
and,
and emoting right at the right,
you know,
right at the right word.
And it just,
it just didn't feel like,
yeah.
When,
when,
when a show comes around
that's very specifically Asian,
it's hiring all these Asian people.
There's like,
there's a tremendous amount of
attention from the Asian community.
Everybody gets very excited.
Like,
I have Asian friends that were actors
and they will get very bummed out that
there's no roles for Asian and they'd get
really pissed off and I would bring up
like when John Wayne Played Kingus Khan
boiling read Mickey,
the Charlie Chan,
Charlie Chan was a white car,
had the tape on the ice.
Yeah.
So now that there's like
an actual agent show,
like what has the response
been like you're an actor
who was like the wire dude.
Basically every Asian
person is hitting you up.
Like you'll kind of be bubbles.
Everybody wants to be bubbling.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's been like,
you know,
I mean the overwhelming like just
positivity and negativity and,
and you know,
skepticism and it's everything.
It's because it's the only one you,
and is there any
inter Asian like anger,
like you are being a Korean guy
playing a guy who's from Taiwan?
You know,
I haven't experienced it personally.
I'm sure it's out there.
I had my own issues with that too.
Like I actually went to Eddie like early
on after I found out the show is being
picked up the pilot and I was like,
I don't think that this
doesn't feel right.
I don't think I should
be playing this part.
Really handle super earnest about it.
Yeah,
I like wigged out about it.
I actually had a nervous breakdown
about it cause nervous breakdown and not
nervous about a panic attack.
I had a panic attack.
How does that go?
Just like I thought I was going to die
like literally like the night before I
was,
I couldn't sleep and
I have to keep moving.
I was like,
and I knew it was because of this cause
I was just so in my outs like I don't
think I should be playing this part.
This is like a big moment.
Yeah.
And that's part of the reason that got
me to that thought was because after the
show got picked up it was
already all over the Internet.
Like amongst Asian people.
Like super excited for it,
you know?
Yeah.
The great yellow hopes shit.
It was just,
Oh my God,
our dicks are all going to get bigger.
February 4th my Dick is going
to be six and a half inches.
Everybody gonna have six and a half
inch sticks on February 4th so you,
it's fascinating though.
He was like,
Oh man,
I don't know if I should be,
I don't know if I'm the one,
you know?
And it's just because of the fact that
you're Korean playing guy was Chinese.
Yeah.
I mean that was a big part of it.
Also,
I had my,
you know,
I had issues with the character and
we talked about it and I had like,
I was like,
man,
I don't know.
I just don't feel like this is
right.
I think that thing was,
was Randall is so earnest and,
and the reason like I've really bonded
with Randall through the whole thing is
there's a lot of people that
lie to you in Hollywood.
There's a lot of fake
motherfuckers out here.
Wait a minute.
What are you saying?
Oh,
I can't be a part of the show
and I got a go have a meeting.
But no,
like he would,
we would talk really openly
and honestly about the script,
like the things that didn't
seem to like represent my pop's,
that,
that weren't totally there
because you don't shows,
they always have like a really powerful
woman and a kind of a schlubby dude.
My Dad walked around the crib in his
underwear with a k just chilling.
Did he really?
Yeah.
Okay.
He cocked it on my friend once when we
were just like watching cartoons in my
dad was like,
ha ha.
And I was like,
Whoa,
bad ass.
I mean,
like I met him.
The dude is,
I mean,
not only bad it,
he's just like a diner.
He's like,
Eddie,
he's like this a dynamic person.
You know,
he didn't mean a bed because my friend
had been asking him about it and he
always wanted to see it.
So my dad ones I just came
out with and it was like Bong,
bong.
Yeah.
So,
so,
you know,
we don't see much of that,
that in the character of the show.
But you know,
with that being said,
like,
you know my issues were just like,
yeah,
I don't want him to be like always like
the funny one are always the inept kind
of classic Sitcom Dad.
I want him to kind of,
I want him to do well.
I want him to work hard.
I want to be a good example for the kids.
You know,
because again,
we're the only Asian show.
It's important that like I
don't just play that one lane.
I want him to be more fleshed out.
You know
that is a real issue.
Right?
If you're the only Asian
show on television,
you definitely don't want
to be a negative stereotype.
You don't want to like play into all
the bullshit that is already out there.
The negative stereotypes.
Yeah.
That's a tricky,
tricky position.
Huh?
Is that why you felt like you
were real nervous about it though?
Pat was deaf that that was it.
See,
I mean also like in
combination with the accent,
you know,
if you have an accent,
that's one.
Thank you.
Hit me with some of that accident.
Come on down.
But,
but,
but the thing is just say fuck
you Joe Rogan with that accident.
Say that.
Just try it.
No,
but,
but fuck you.
Fuck you.
Joe Logan and Xingrei.
Yeah,
exactly.
Uh,
no,
but yeah,
exactly.
You got an accent and we
just seen throughout history,
Hollywood history,
it's like as if there's an accent.
This character is one dimensional.
You know,
David Show had this fucking great posts.
It was one point in time.
We pulled his DVD asa podcast off the
year and you put this great quote on his
website about Jackie Chan.
He goes,
how come Jackie Chan never
got to fuck or finger bang?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Totally killed off this whole thing about
everyone's afraid of the yellow man.
I want,
he talks about fear of a black planet.
We're on me on my style.
That was a huge moment
for like Asian kids.
Yeah.
You remember chatting,
Leanna,
Leah,
if you could've just made out with the,
I swear like that,
would it just life,
would it tripled
in that theater?
They don't even like,
they don't even shake hands.
What is that?
And that's a Romeo and Juliet
that was like the fuck.
I don't even shake hands
except for walking dead.
That's the only time with Asian guy wins.
That's the thing is like there
had be a Zombie Apocalypse Asian
too.
To get some pussy.
It has to be a Zombie apocalypse.
That dude had to be a motherfucker,
a few white dudes that want to
fuck that check you in that show.
But she's the hottest
chick on that show by far,
by far.
By far.
And that's a big victory
for the guy was Asian here.
We caught one day.
Yeah,
that was a good one.
Yeah.
Well this is
anger and resentment in
the Asian community too.
When Asian girls will
exclusively date white guys.
Yeah.
I used to get mad,
but now I'm just like,
it's cool.
There's billions of us.
That is a weird thing though,
right?
I mean that's a common occurrence
when I was in college that way,
that that were like,
yeah,
that would definitely like get me upset,
hit home.
But I'm the same.
Like,
I'm just like,
dude,
it's,
you know,
my thing is everybody deals with their
identity and their own way and it's like
if you,
if you not loving someone
for the right reasons,
it may rear its head in three months,
six months,
six years,
but eventually you're
going to deal with it.
Yeah.
And it's just not my job to be judge
and jury Wickham machineries and white
dudes.
It's kind of,
you know,
shorty's that's,
that's your prerogative,
man.
I used to get tightened college
tighten college.
I was always about white
chicks with big butts.
Anyway,
so
who isn't UPA exactly.
Paul Knox is a number one
dropdown on Bang Bros,
I think.
Yeah,
that's perfect
ass white girl.
If you don't know what Pa WG means.
Yeah.
There's something about,
well,
it's just such an anomaly.
You know,
you find a white girl with perfect cas.
We were in a,
Tony Hinchcliffe and I were in
this coffee shop the other day.
We met this black girl from Kenya who,
she had an ash.
She turned around and we both went like
that and just looked at each other like,
Jesus is that real?
And then we talked about it
for like an hour afterwards.
Like you don't ever see that
on any other nationality.
It's only black chicks from Africa.
I mean she had her ass was
like in the middle of her back,
you know,
west,
west Indian or come up with,
it's like Caribbean,
west Indian,
you'll get it right.
And right now there's a lot of
chicks with fake bloods out there.
If you look at Instagram,
sometimes there's a lot
of these girls that,
you know,
they never showed the backside.
Then all of a sudden,
like six weeks,
there's a gap in photos and then bang.
And you're like,
Whoa,
is that,
you mean people here and,
and the and yeah,
that's a thing.
Yeah.
There's a few girls in New
York for Israel that's like,
Yo,
it's huge in Brazil and Colombia.
But in New York now there's a lot of
New York girls could be fake blood.
You know what's fucked up about that?
It's like a girl can get her a but
big by working out and lift weights.
But you can't do anything about your
breasts if you want your breasts to be
larger.
I don't think they have
a solution to that yet.
But if you want your asked to be big,
all you gotta do it.
You Lazy Bitch,
just do some squats.
You don't have to stick plastic in here.
My ass is tight.
I got to workout.
Beautiful.
I knew a dude
who had chest implants.
Oh,
what?
Yeah,
he got who?
Just implants.
That's weird.
It was a comedian.
He decided he would,
you know,
he wanted to be a sitcom star and that's
chicken chest and instead of working
out,
I mean I think you
worked out a little bit,
but he had peck implants.
I feel like,
I feel like fat Jew,
I think I talked to him.
I think he wants breast and close
fat Jew that this comedian fed shoe.
He's awesome.
That's his name.
Yeah,
that's his name.
Yeah.
He sends me photos like this to,
he sends me wild photos
of Turkey testicles.
This is super weird stuff,
man.
But he's the best.
You have to see this.
He sent this to me for thanksgiving,
but yeah.
Hmm.
So it's a Turkey with his balls.
Yeah.
You can out of the hole.
It's a Turkey.
He cut out putting balls
in the photo of his balls.
Yeah.
It's just,
it was an acceptable way
for him to send his balls.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Is he a guy in New York?
He,
he's in New York.
He's been a homemaker for a few years.
He was like in this rap group,
team face lift.
Super futuristic to you.
You got to have him on the show.
All right.
If I'm in fat Jew.
Interesting.
That's my man.
Strange name.
Yeah.
So you guys have been filming
this for how many months now?
Ooh.
Since uh,
we ended right before Christmas.
And did it go through like,
um,
I've been on a sitcom news radio from the
beginning to like the one of the first
episodes to the end.
It's like they grow and everybody sort
of finds their own rhythm and people get
fired and writers,
new writers come in.
Do you guys have go through all that?
We didn't like that.
Only because we didn't start
airing while we're in production.
I feel like those things
happen when you're,
when it starts airing and
then the feedback comes and,
and you know the,
the lower it maybe if the ratings are
like on the edge and then they start
panicking,
oh we've got to make
changes but we didn't.
We like we're literally
in a bubble kind of thing.
It's a gift and a curse that your mid
season when you're mid season they buy all
the episodes and they're going to all air.
Yeah.
So did they do a pilot first?
Yeah,
the pilot's great.
They did the pilot pilots actually my
favorite episode of the whole season.
So he's did a pilot.
And then how long before
they decided to pick it up?
Had
a little bit of a break.
Yeah,
we finished it.
I feel like we delivered it in March.
Right.
And then we found out in May.
Yeah,
beginning of man months.
Yeah.
Two months.
I didn't think it was gonna get picked up.
Not because I didn't
think it was good cause I,
nothing gets picked up
but nothing gets picked.
That number one and that no Asian
family sitcom gets picked up one ever.
One 20 years ago.
Yeah,
it was fine.
I knew it would get picked up.
I told everybody,
I was like,
Yo man,
see what chase bank,
Chase Bank.
Eddie knew.
I was just like,
you know,
I mean I've been in the trenches
as an actor for it for a long end.
Like these things don't happen.
They don't happen.
And then it happened.
I was like,
well they occasionally happened.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I feel like you,
you will shit to happen.
Like when my whole life I just feel like,
you know,
you gotta like will it and just believe
it and if you don't then it really
won't.
It has to you everything had
the Mojo all has to line up.
It helps.
It helps if you believe it does.
There's a lot of people out there
that watched the secret and thought,
I'm going to change.
Nothing fucking happen.
No,
I think you have.
It's essential to believe and
then there's still a lot of shit,
but if you don't believe it,
you good luck.
Yeah.
It's,
there's a vibration
that you have to catch.
You have to be on a frequency and all
these things have to align together in
order for it to be successful.
Yeah.
And,
and you can feel it.
Like you can really feel the energy.
Like we had a good energy on our show
and I think it's because everyone,
this was the biggest thing.
Anyone will not,
you had a lot of other hits
but like constants Hudson,
the kids,
you know,
it's Melvin the producers
first thing that's his own.
It was the biggest thing
I've done and you know,
for everybody was just
like humbling to be there.
Happy,
happy to get there.
And then once we got there we were like,
let's Breck shot,
you know,
let's do this.
Well you should act man.
You got such a great personality
that all the time I tell him,
I'm like,
I'm writing something for you at.
That's why it made sense to
me that you were on a sitcom.
Like there's a lot of chefs,
if you told me they were
on a sitcom would be like,
what?
Yeah,
like Emeril.
I didn't know exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah,
and Merle had a fucking said calm.
I think it was called Emeril.
Yeah.
It was like some fucking NBC disaster.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
He's actually pretty
fucking cool in person.
Like I chill with Emeril on top.
Chef dude is,
especially in New Orleans.
I got to hang with them in New Orleans.
Cool.
Dude.
That's a spot.
Yeah,
that's his spot.
But like,
no,
I,
I definitely,
I told my agent,
I was like,
Yo,
if there's any roles out there for
an Asian Joe Peshy fucking sign,
that's what I want to be.
An Asian Joe,
Joe Pegi Goodfellows or
Joe Pesci lethal weapon.
Oh,
like my cousin Vinny.
Ah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
you could totally do you.
That's why when I heard
that you were doing it,
I was like,
oh wow.
What did we,
this fucking versatile motherfucker
could shine a voice acting,
but no,
I got it.
I got to do the acting it,
it'll be fun.
I'm excited.
The voice acting to that.
I mean that's like,
I feel like that was a huge,
I mean that wasn't in the original,
that wasn't in the original.
Nafta kind of came in like
how can we make this better?
And then they came up with the idea we
got to have Eddie and that like changed
it.
It like really made a,
solidified the show,
you know,
and,
and framed it in the right way.
It happened in the edit.
I think it was just in the edit.
They were like,
Yo,
you should fucking
Kevin Arnold this thing.
Yeah.
You know,
I was so excited.
I was really,
they told him I was playing ball
when Melvin called me and was like,
Oh lucky I do this.
I was playing football.
Getting pockets.
Yeah.
Is there any way they could write you in?
I mean,
who would you play if you
were going to be on that show?
You'll like cousin,
cousin Eddie would be sick or cousin.
I got a cousin
Allen or something.
But yeah,
like cousin.
Yeah,
you could be like kids cousin.
It's always given them like
sneaky advice in trouble.
You know,
leading them astray.
Temptation,
life,
man.
The kid was telling me,
it's like,
Yo,
like I like girls now,
like word.
That's great.
That's really great.
You like girls?
And I was like,
do you have like a girlfriend or whatever?
He's like,
no,
there's this girl I like,
but I'm afraid to talk to her.
And I was like,
well what are you going to do
then you should go talk to her.
And he's like,
no,
I don't want to talk to her.
And I was like,
well what do you want to do?
And he's like,
I kind of want to touch her.
I was like,
good.
So I'm like,
Yo,
when she gets out of class,
just kind of bumped into
her boobs with your elbow.
No,
don't tell him he's like,
what?
And I was like,
no.
Yeah,
you got to just kind of
bumping into the booth.
Can't tell him that.
And you definitely can't admit that
on the Internet because if he goes,
if he goes and does that now
that's like sexual assault.
It's not that you did
that in middle school.
You come out of like seventh grade.
I lived in a different world.
My friend,
this is the world,
the Internet,
social justice warriors.
He just asked that dude,
come on.
Rape.
No,
no,
no.
In this world,
your illegally touching a sexual
organ with your elbow on purpose.
It's not an accident.
You're pretending it's an accident.
Fuck man.
Do I have to apologize?
Dark.
We're so sorry.
Boobs with,
I'm so sorry to all those boobs out there.
Especially if the girl doesn't
want him to touch her boobs,
then it's really sexual assault.
Do you know?
I'm sure he's a good kid.
I'm sure she wouldn't mind it
if that's not sure enough rent.
Randall,
you never like kind of just brushed up
against the pedal and are meant to it.
Even if I cannot recall the only one.
I'm the only one that was
running my Nautica competition.
Fleece.
Gabriel,
stop beating that Cosby horse
and start running towards you.
It sticks.
No Man.
No [inaudible] not on that.
No.
Come on.
It doesn't matter.
There's so many people out there,
they're looking to be angry.
They're looking to find something.
They just,
they can't brush it off as something
innocent or joking around and especially
when it comes to something
like asking a young kid,
giving him advice,
had a bump in with chicks tits,
maybe.
Maybe I did fuck up.
Do you fucked up?
Fuck it doesn't matter.
Which is what you tell them to do.
Tell him to let her watch him on TV
and then she'll probably like him.
Compelling.
All right,
I'm going to have to call
Hudson tonight and be like,
Yo,
remember that technique I told you about
kind of brushing or pick a new plan.
New Plan.
Uncle Joe wants her to
watch the show first.
Trust uncle Joe,
the pussy buses coming.
All right.
They're loading it up right now.
Once you get on TV,
they're gonna want to broad
brushed her tits up against you.
Then it's wait for them
to brush up against you.
That sexual assault,
nobody complains about that.
Sexual assault is not a guy.
Lives there were complaining
about a girl brushing her tits up.
I remember the first time I
saw up a skirt was incredible.
I wasn't earth space science class.
I was an earth space science and I would,
oh this,
there was this one Colombian
chick that was so fly,
like always came done up,
was the first one to be
wearing heels in school.
How old was she?
Well,
we were both 14 so we were both
14 she might've went 15 heels.
She's wearing heels.
And I remember she had this like hounds
tooth dress on and I was just like,
Yo,
her legs look like fucking Hams right now.
Oh,
they look like Christmas.
Honeybaked Hams in there.
And I could not stop looking.
And I remember she turned to me,
smiled and just open her legs and nodded.
And I was like looked.
And it was just peach fuzz and bear.
And I was Oh,
oh,
lifelong.
She had no underwear on,
no underwear.
Oh my gosh.
She's just flashed.
I was 14 and I was a site and I was,
I was like me.
She was like,
yeah.
Wow.
Oh,
like this is for you.
Yeah.
And I was,
I was cooked.
I couldn't talk to her.
Yeah.
That was my first time.
But yeah,
so maybe I should've just told Hudson
just keeps staring be at the right place
at the right.
Yes,
Darren,
they call that I rape.
Oh Yay.
You're going to have to issue on it.
And you've been reading the New Yorker?
No,
I just,
I like to,
I like to read super progressive
websites where they're just out of their
fucking mind.
Yeah.
Mostly people that no one wants to
fuck and with they're trying to do is
establish these parameters for what
is appropriate and not appropriate.
It's mostly against,
that's the thing though.
That doesn't work because like I'm all
about women's rights and and ideologies
and all those things is I just went and
did a whole piece in Japan about why the
birth rate is declining there and I was
like championing the fact that we've
asked women to go into the workplace
but then not redistribute the duties of
home and childbearing and child
bearing and it's just like we have to
redistribute the duties
that are traditionally left
for women because they're
working now we all got to share but then
when you just have rules of like don't
do this and don't do that,
you're not really understanding
the relationship of like men,
women in society.
You just setting weird ass rules then
make everybody upset and uncomfortable.
It's also like who's
setting those rules like?
Like one of them is about drinking.
Like they're saying that men and women
when they're having sex with this,
it's hilarious blog that I like to read
occasionally and they were trying to say
that if men and women,
if they're both,
if they're drinking,
if you're drinking and
you have sex with someone,
it's rape.
Including if a woman is
sober and the man is drunk,
if the woman has sex with a drunk man,
she's raping him,
which is raping her fucking hilarious.
It is hilarious.
Might be my favorite position.
If you're drunk,
you ain't me being drunk.
Her being sober.
That is my favorite position.
The language that they use is that they,
if you're drunk,
they put you in a position
where you cannot consent.
You're not able to consent
because you're drunk.
I mean,
which is,
it's first of all,
it's rude towards women because
some women have to be drunk.
They,
they,
it's a strategy.
They did it on purpose.
They want to be drunk so that they could
deal with the fact they're gonna let
some dude fuck.
A lot of dudes are annoying as shit
and women get horny and I'm like,
God,
I want someone to hug me,
but I don't want to just
idiot wrote a few shots back.
Yeah,
we all do that.
Good.
You know,
I can understand it if it's like in
fraternities and sororities cause the,
the rampant rape on college campuses is
insane right now because at that age is,
nobody knows what the fuck they're doing.
But like adults,
man,
like who's having sex without drinking?
Seriously,
like without some combination
of like wines and extra,
we'd like nobody's having sex.
Sober people.
We would be Japan sober people.
You know,
people who are like in
the program or something.
Alcoholics anonymous people.
What do they do it half are terrible sex.
Go jogging,
get a runner's high for us and then
hold the breath,
go spinning and then smash.
Then you've got to shower.
I ain't gotta shower twice
to fuck us up with that.
Yeah,
I know the high might wear
off it as hard as the last,
nearly as long as I get an edible.
Nice cold brew coffee.
Six.
I would get crazy logs.
Y'All and dry mouth with coffee.
Sex are real for real.
If I drank coffee and
then she sat on my face,
there would be serious problems.
If you drink coffee,
your com is more likely
to get a girl pregnant.
Really?
You know the sperm is more active drink,
green tea,
even.
Same thing.
Caffeine.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's caffeine.
Caffeine makes your spur more act.
That's for real thing.
It's safe these days.
Yeah.
Nothing's fucking nothing.
Say Nothing.
There's nothing safe including sex.
Yeah.
Let's say so point being,
don't tell this 12 year old kid the
wrong shit because as the climate becomes
more and more hostile towards men,
it's going to get crazier and just really
think we should ask the twitters and
just don't be last Twitter ever.
I'm just going to correct
this and tell him that.
Just stare and tell
her to watch your show.
This stay offline.
They'll Google your name.
Doesn't exist.
Just don't exist.
Keep moving.
Oh Man.
Well the things that usually
get away with when you,
you know like natural boy,
girl type shit.
It's like,
you know,
people take offense to that stuff now.
Yeah,
like the anti whole thing.
When he just,
he goes to grab her.
I don't remember.
Annie Hall.
Oh,
it was great.
He's like,
it's like Alvie singer as a kid and he
goes to kiss the girl and the girl's
like,
even throid talks about a latency period.
Alvey yeah.
I don't remember.
It was so long ago.
It's a great movie.
Woody Allen,
who's another one.
Yeah,
free Bao bad example.
I shouldn't put myself down.
I'm saying this is just
change the subject.
Have you ever seen those photos of woody
Allen with the girl on his lap when she
was a little girl,
when he was the dad and then
the two of them together.
The girl who,
the girl,
his wife,
his wife now while she was sitting on
his lap when she was a little girl at a
basketball game and then many years
later she sitting next to him holding his
hand as his wife.
It's crazy.
That's like,
Yo,
it's weird.
Well that's seeing it laid out like
that.
It's very dark.
Yeah.
It's like there's one thing,
like if you hear about it like,
well maybe he didn't spend
a lot of time with her,
but then you see the photo with her on
his lap at a basketball game and then,
yeah,
and when you see them now,
even in the garden,
it's bugged.
It's totally bugged out.
Yeah.
It's amazing that he goes out with her.
I mean that's got balls.
Yeah.
I mean that guy's got crazy,
but oh,
do you need to be ringside or we're
courtside that fucking pad with your
daughter or wife.
No,
stay in the nose.
Claim with your daughter.
Wife didn't even go watch it.
They have it on TV.
Yeah.
You got Voodoo.
What the fuck,
man?
It just seems like it's not a good move,
but I don't,
I don't think people care.
He got no fucks given that dude.
Just like,
I think because of that,
people don't care his,
I mean he just got a big deal.
I don't know if you read
about it like Amazon,
Amazon TV deal,
like he's doing like shows for
Amazon now and even a thing,
you know.
Well,
he's a really good director.
He writes and directs
a new movie every year.
Have you ever seen how
he does everything to,
he does it all.
What a typewriter.
No Way.
Oh yeah,
there's a video.
See if you pull it up,
Jeremy.
There's a,
it's a fascinating video.
Woody Allen explaining
his writing process.
He's got a video,
he's got a typewriter,
and then when he does changes,
when he doesn't need sort of a
change to one of his scripts,
he cuts a piece of paper out and
fucking tape sits down over the other.
The other place,
I mean him and him and Wes Anderson,
definitely my favorite director.
What do you owe on this typewriter?
It's kind of fucking weird,
man.
I mean,
I think this is one of the
ways he avoids the Internet.
This to stay sane
house was always full of clarinet,
reeds,
ovary.
It was 16 still works like a Tang and
it's a German typewriter and it's an
Olympia part of,
Oh,
I've had it my whole life.
It cost me $40 I think the guy told me
it would be around long after my death
and I've typed everything,
uh,
that I've ever written,
every script,
every New Yorker piece,
everything I've ever done
on this type of that.
You used to have a metal
piece on top covering this,
which I lost 30 years ago.
One advantage obviously
to the word processors.
You can electronically cut and paste.
What do you do when you
have to cut and paste?
If I'm typing something,
I have my scissors here and
I have a lot of these things,
these little stapling machines.
So if I'm typing something,
I typed in the box like this and then
nobody is really tighten this stuff.
It looks terrible on the page,
so I have to type it because I have
arrows and all kinds of things,
but when they come to a nice pile,
then I cut that part off and
staple it on to something else.
With this time it's very,
but it works.
It works very well.
She is due to sewing screenplays,
so there's no problem.
How bizarre.
I fucking love it.
I love this dude,
like he's just so I,
I'd may be people if you can't
forgive any of that shit,
it's really,
really fucked up.
I think people just aren't shocked by
it because he's such an idiosyncratic,
like,
yeah,
we are dude.
It doesn't say nothing with him,
surprisingly,
but yeah.
Well have you ever seen his old stand up?
I have a record of his,
like an old,
old record of his and eh,
I mean he,
it was pretty good.
I mean,
it's like weird stories.
Well,
he's a fucking pervert man.
Yeah,
he was always a perfect
this some stand up,
uh,
his,
you know,
that stand up black and
white is near a staircase.
It's from old,
just look like rare woody Allen stand up.
All his work is about sex and psychology,
all of it.
And we'll,
with the younger women,
like that's like a theme.
He's a pervert man.
Just like,
it's a rare old piece.
That's it.
65 rare.
It's,
it's hilarious.
Listen to him talk.
Is he the Bot,
which is this fabulous museum?
A Bot.
And when I was younger,
I used to hang out a lot.
The museum in search of a
meaningful social relationships.
He used to look for girl
I saw on the rural one,
uh,
no by Rubens,
but a real succulent nude
huntress stabbing to death,
a war hawk.
And I got very emotionally
involved with the painting,
you know,
to God had to restrain me.
Alright,
the lick,
some of the oil off the cap.
Hi.
Where is it that I could meet the kind
of girl that would pose for that type
picture I had in my neighborhood,
there's an art supply shop that deals
and offbeat things that I read it down
there and I get the name of
the oddest bottle off the wall.
I call her up and I came on very
strong like an artist was it,
you know,
I used a lot of 30 autistic terms.
Like right
though I was just adorable
and we agreed on a price,
you know,
hung up,
rest stop and my Ma Baret you know,
Harvey's Bristol cream on the hair
too much.
What I want to be
now or later.
There's a knock on my
door and standing there,
just this fabulous woman,
really sensational.
I let her in quickly,
you know,
and I locked the door with my police,
lock the media and I said take
off your clothes right away.
Cause I don't know much about
art but I know what I like.
So he was,
he was always a creeper bed glance.
Yeah.
Graybar.
I mean,
which is getting bad,
you know,
she,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's like that cause view
that Spanish fly bit.
You what I mean like that was
toweling Cosby Spanish fly better,
right?
Or easy.
Yeah.
Especially in that.
And he talked about that on
more than one occasion to,
Oh did he?
Yeah.
There was another thing he talked about
Spanish fly in an interview who's doing
an interview with someone and he
talked about Spanish fly like yeah,
like a casual interview panel,
like do with doing panel on a talk show.
And he talked about Spanish fly.
Oh man,
there's like a part of his daily life.
I mean I wonder what the fuck that was.
You know,
he wouldn't it,
we're never going to
hear it from his mouth,
which is too bad because I mean,
it's almost like you ever see that
documentary iceman portrait of a serial
killer.
No,
no,
no.
It's on Netflix though.
I know what you're talking about.
Hbo Documentary where they sat down with
this guy who was a notorious Hitman,
killed a bunch of people and uh,
they sat down with them and talk
to them about how it started.
Who was the first person he killed,
what was his methods the whole day.
And you hear the guy talk and you hear
his mentality and you understand where
he's coming from.
And he's like,
Whoa,
well you can just have a glimpse into
the eyes of a monster and you kind of
understand like how it went down because
we don't often get a chance to hear
interviews from serial
killers or Hitman or whatever,
but to have Cosby sit down
if he ever did come clean,
like maybe if they ever did arrest him
and he came clean and he started talking
about what he did or why
he did it or you know,
he couldn't help himself
or what was the impulse?
I mean,
I can't imagine because
I don't think like that,
but it's just like maybe,
I don't know,
maybe some people think
they're entitled to Shit.
That's where,
that's where my bay,
right?
That's my guess is that either you
have an impulse you can't control,
but then it's like how can you have so
much control in the rest of your life?
Then I start to think like
you have self control,
so it can't be an impulse thing has to
be that you feel you've justified this in
your mind and you feel entitled to this.
Well,
he has always been a guy that's been
known as being very arrogant and a guy who
is my manager met him and he had a very,
very poor opinion of him.
He said a meeting and be like,
treats everybody like,
like he's a king and like you're
supposed to have like a certain behavior
towards him.
You ever see the shit on a lot of
younger black comics to always give him a
heart.
All of them.
Everyone is dirty.
Chris Rock,
Eddie Murphy,
that famous bit that
Eddie Murphy did and uh,
Eddie Murphy raw where he talked about
he had to call up Richard Pryor cause
bill Cosby saw his standup and
called them up and chastised them,
you know,
and he called up Richard prior to ask
him for advice and bill Cosby because due
to people laugh,
did you get paid?
Well tell bill to have a coke
and a smile and shut the fuck up.
It's like,
it's a famous famous quote fryer.
I'm prior as the greatest,
the greatest.
I feel like there's two
greatest of time is I say,
I always say that Sam Kinison
was the greatest for one year,
for one year.
I don't think anybody was ever stronger,
like,
especially like in that
time in 1986 or 1987.
But he didn't sustain it.
He just kept doing coke and fucking
is material went way downhill.
But over the long term period of time
prior was the greatest and the most
influential has everything.
Everything that most people would hide.
He just,
it was onstage and just said it,
but he had nothing to hide.
Well,
he was a unique,
unique talent man.
Very unique guy.
And you know,
he also was like unique in that he would
be real honest about his drug use and
how the drug use thing was very,
that was a very big part of,
uh,
his standup,
you know,
especially after he tried to kill himself,
and you never felt like
he was telling jokes.
It really just felt like you're just a
naturally funny guy talking about tax
shit.
Yeah.
It never felt like set up punchline,
so,
yeah.
Yeah,
He was just talking,
you know,
it's even though you knew he was,
it's calculated in his delivery,
it was just so comfortable and it's hard
to put it in perspective because back
then if you listen to like some Cosby or
Richard Pryor rather from like 1981 or
something like that,
it's hard to put your brain back in 1981
because it was just a different time.
The world was young.
It was,
it was,
uh,
the media had not had the same
influence that it has now.
Do you think your show,
do you ever wonder like,
man,
like your show going to get
fucked with cause it's censored.
And do you ever think like maybe
it would have been a free or shelf?
I did it on showtime or HBO.
Did you,
did you think about doing it?
He got offers from other
production companies and um,
you know,
th the thing for me was I
wanted to fight this battle.
I wanted to take the story to
network television and be like,
let's,
let's take this to western Michigan.
You know,
like going to cable,
that's preaching to the choir.
That's me,
you,
Randall,
my friends,
we all watch showtime,
Hbo,
Netflix,
and you know,
I have the vice show,
but there's a huge difference in the
people we're going to reach with this show
and my vice show.
Is that vice show the same name?
Uh,
no.
They change will.
They bought the name from vice,
so yeah.
Yeah.
I had licensed it to vice and then it got,
it got sold over,
but it's cool.
Vice was awesome because
ABC needed the name.
Who was the name of the book?
And for me it was,
they were,
they were calling it four
East Orlando Far East Orlando.
If it wasn't such a bad name,
I wouldn't have taken the
name from the vice show.
But you know,
Shane and those guys are great man.
Like they really did me a favor.
They didn't have to do that.
And that's why I fuck with them.
So heavy chain doesn't give a fuck.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He does it right.
The gentleman he doesn't give a shame,
does the right thing all the time.
I love that dude.
Yeah.
And like I'm very critical of,
you know,
my experience with 20th
and ABC and those things.
But you know,
I would never lie.
Like I'm not just here to
say nice things about vice.
Those dudes always come through.
They always do.
They do the right thing.
And so we put it ABC cause I was like,
we can't go out with foist Orlando.
Then name was fucked.
Sorry.
What does that even mean?
Yeah.
Chinks life dreams.
Where dreamworks,
the Chinks Life.
Did you grow up in Orlando?
Is that why they did it?
Yeah,
I was,
yeah,
it takes place in Orlando.
Yeah.
Like in the 90s was a dark place.
Dark fucking place of people don't know.
No,
you got Disneyland and then everything
that's outside of Disneyland.
Yeah,
very strange.
I took a lot of ecstasy to
stay positive in Orlando.
Yeah.
But you,
you,
when did you develop the New York accent?
I've always been,
I've always talked like this.
It's super fucking weird.
It's just in the hip hop.
I think it's hip hop.
It's watching so much basketball and then,
um,
it's,
my parents don't speak English at home,
so my English is learned.
So in a way I think it's,
you choose the way you talk,
right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's just I want all I did,
I just watched gangster movies,
listen to hip hop,
watch basketball,
and it's,
it is what,
it always sounded like this,
that's an interesting man.
Even when I was in Orlando,
I remember there was a few girls,
I was like,
you from Brooklyn?
And I was no,
DC,
Orlando,
Pittsburgh.
And then I've been in New York,
Brooklyn for like 10 years.
So then it just crystallized it for me.
How long you allowed to like how long do
you have to live in a place before you
accept the accent?
You know,
man,
like if you're from Georgia and then you
moved to New Jersey and then you start
talking like you're from New Jersey
and then you go back to Georgia,
they're going to go,
what the fuck man.
But you know,
even if you spend a week in Atlanta,
because in Atlanta you just tossed it
just sizzurp and alcohol all weekend and
you get,
you get so faded that you,
I end up saying things a little weird.
Even after a week in Atlanta,
you get that fucked up
and you go to Atlanta.
I get fucked up in Atlanta,
shouts to cooker,
arrived my man cooker.
We went out to follies last time.
It was awesome.
So sizzurp that's that
shit with coding in it.
Yeah.
But you know,
asap yams pass like a week ago,
nobody knows who was.
There is no closet that the guy asap yams
who's like the architect and the whole
asap mob.
This rap group from Harlem and he,
he had this crew called the blackout
boys and it's like my boy Ron had a tee
shirt,
did the logo blackout boys
and then they had a crew,
they got a podcast but he passed
like a week ago known scissor,
Xanax Dude.
And so they haven't,
they haven't said why.
No,
Yeah,
but you know,
after it happened,
I know a lot of friends
of mine were just like,
do we,
we can't,
we got to chill with this.
We got to chill.
Well that codeine syrup that,
I never did it,
but I did do some nyquil.
I've talked about on the podcast before
I took nyquil once I was really sick and
I got that old Nyquil does is like
in the 1990s and it was wonderful.
Nyquil like,
like
the real Nyquil,
like all type of thing.
Yeah.
There's coding and some others to no,
I didn't get,
I mean I took what the dose
we were supposed to take.
You'll jelly leg.
Oh good jelly legs.
Yeah.
I was just lying in bed like the world
was giving me a big beautiful hug.
All love.
It's just like,
it just felt so good.
I remember,
I'll never forget,
I remember thinking this
stuff is a wonderful,
yeah,
it's like drinking Robitussin and in
middle school or high school like I would
just drink Robitussin fun.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause he couldn't get alcohol.
Me and my boys is drink Robitussin.
So how did it get into
the rap community syrup?
What happens?
Is there a
Houston,
Houston and Atlanta.
It was southern.
It was just,
you know,
pimp c rip like pimps.
He died too.
But I mean those dudes all the,
yeah,
the rap a lot.
Dude's cause it was,
slows your heart rate down.
That's how he died too.
He died from syrup.
He thought yet yams we don't yams,
nobody has confirmed so
nobody knows how he passed.
But like people know how old was he?
It's like an epidemic.
And was he 26 yeah,
it was like 26 I think.
I'm not sure.
I'm dad's fucking sad.
[inaudible] pass.
Yeah.
That's why I,
I mean I'm to,
I'm not joking about it
anymore cause it's like,
dude,
it's,
it's pretty dangerous.
It'll creep up on you.
You think it's just cough syrup,
but it'll creep up on you.
Wow.
Damn,
that's a,
that's a thing that with
the youth today though,
I know there's a lot of kids
that are drinking concert.
Yeah.
I mean I did it growing up
and like not all the time.
Maybe like once or twice a
year or something like that.
But I never saw it as that serious.
But now you start to see people pass.
It's serious.
You know what?
They're doing it probably every day.
I'm not sure,
man.
I'm not sure.
It's just not to be fucked with.
I don't,
I also people,
people in Philly like,
um,
Harlem,
you'll do pancakes and syrup,
which is you dropped his annex into the
coding and then that's just good night.
Oh my God,
that's good night.
Hallmark.
God,
we were in Boston two weeks ago and there
was this dude that was fucked up and
he was standing in front of the w
hotel and you're standing there,
his pants were like half falling down
and it just kept leaning forward.
Like he was going to face plant.
Well,
like he's gone down,
he's going down and he would catch himself
and then he moved forward every time
he did it to the point where he was in
the middle of the fucking road in the
middle of the road,
which is fucked up.
And then leaning forward.
And uh,
my friend was like,
he's drunk.
And I'm like,
that guy is not drunk.
That is some next level
shit that's not drunk.
He's on some pills or something.
Yeah,
but he kept leaning forward
and then we're like,
he's going,
hey face plant catch himself.
We've watched him like five minutes.
My friend was like,
rescue him.
Like what you rescue him?
Rescue in that guy.
You rescue that guy.
You got to go back to his
childhood figuring out what
the fuck made him the way
he is.
You got to take a time machine,
kill his parents.
You know there's a lot of shit.
You got to do the rescue that guy.
Yeah.
It'll put the hooks in you man.
Like that's why you know
kids don't do drugs.
Right.
It's rough man.
It's rough.
You not need it.
He just smoked some weed kids.
Yeah.
I don't even really smell weed that,
I mean I smoked like three nights ago,
but I've stopped having weed in the crib.
Like I'll smoke when I'm out.
Yeah,
because I noticed like I went to some
family shit and I noticed I would get
really depressed when I smoked.
Like it would just make me
depressed and I was like,
this really is a depressant,
so I just switched socially now in one
way or the images or like when I'm really
sad about like when
there's something going on,
I feel like I don't have
my own self control.
If I'm smoking weed,
like I can control the
emotions and block things out,
but once I smoke weed it's just like
it'll hit you or makes you hyper aware.
Yes.
Super aware.
Yeah.
Wallow in it sometimes does.
That's not protecting you,
but I always feel like it's the,
the plant is trying to let me know all
the real shit that I'm dealing with and
all the dangers of all the
shit that I'm dealing with,
so it makes,
that's like what we're paranoia comes
from when people say weed makes me
paranoid,
I'm like,
we should be fucking paranoid.
If you're paying attention
to the weed is doing,
is letting you aware,
be letting you become aware of all the
variables that may be pushing aside or
putting blinders on.
Yeah.
I think I just been stressed lately.
Lot of shit going on in
my life and I was like,
Whoa,
I can't,
I can't look at all of this 24 hours.
I have to be able to
just get away from this.
And when I was smoking weed,
it was like,
Kaboom,
you just unmarinated in it.
And I was like,
I can't,
I can't do this man.
So I got it out of the house now
just smoking when I'm with friends,
you know.
There you go.
That's a smart,
well I think I'll everything you know,
you need moderation.
You can't just be high all day every day.
The [inaudible] breaks before too,
right?
Oh yeah,
I take weeks.
Yeah,
I'll take weeks off of it.
go on vacation or whatever.
I always take breaks.
I've never gotten
anything from smoking it,
but like I,
I've been like eating it on occasion and
I know some shit right here and we'll
get you something
totally different eating.
I feel good eating it,
but okay.
It just doesn't do it.
Well,
I'll explain it because I've explained
it a million times in the podcast.
People are tired of hearing that,
but when you eat it,
it's a totally different drug.
When you eat it,
it's process by your liver and it
becomes something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite.
It's four to five times
more psychoactive than THC,
but it's a totally different truck.
It's way more powerful.
That's why you can have like one of those
little 75 milligram THC candies or 15
you can have a 15 milligram
THC few Joey Diaz.
He go with the 75 those
15 milligram THC candies.
It just give you a nice feeling,
man.
Good.
Yeah.
Relax there.
You ironman with the eating because I,
if I eat,
I bug a bug out.
I can smoke.
It's about the volume.
It's like,
yeah,
you just got to get the right
guy to sell you the right amount.
That's what it is.
The right amount is,
I feel like 20 milligrams is good and
you get crazy and you start getting into
50 and 75 and you know.
Yeah,
I know dudes who go deep,
like my friend Joey,
he goes deep.
Joey,
Joey chomp to one fifty's.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He'll have panic attacks and
she didn't have no planes.
I ate,
I ate at Endeca beef jerky and I ate the
whole jerky myself was supposed to be
the host between like a couple
people and I thought I died.
I woke up my brother,
I thought I died and I was like,
I'm a ghost,
I'm going to take me to the hospital.
And he took me to the hospital and I'm
doing jumping jacks in the emergency
room,
straight jumping jacks.
And they're like,
why are you doing
jumping jacks and the er?
And I was like,
I need to feel alive.
I need to fill up my hardest money.
I was say if I stop,
I'm going to die.
And the doctor rolled up on me,
he's like sand,
there's nothing I can do for you.
I could really,
really,
I'm doing jumping jacks.
And he's like,
I have one piece of advice and I'll go,
what is it?
He goes,
if you're going to eat,
we'd don't be such a pussy about it.
Oh but it got me sober because I was like,
yeah,
the doctor woke me out of it.
Cause are all of a sudden I was like,
wait,
so you say I'm not going to die?
He goes,
you're not going to die
if you stop being a pussy.
Just stop it.
Wow.
This doctor said this.
How old was the doctor do?
He was like a 40 year old white dude.
Really cool in Houston.
I did this on the road in Houston.
This Hughes.
Yeah.
I don't need to be in Houston and Atlanta.
I just get in trouble.
Why Houston?
Atlanta.
You could,
you could just get it.
I had like a leader of something.
It was some sorta like vodka,
some shitty Varga.
We rolled up to the smoothie king cause
you could get the smoothie king drive
through,
dump out,
have your smoothie,
fill the rest with vodka and
scissor and then just goodnight.
Oh yeah.
There's a place in West Palm does the,
the uh,
Improv in west palm was right.
It was connected to this place.
I forget the name of it,
but they used to have these
drinks that were like,
ah,
it was like,
like a,
a wake of frosty.
Like,
what are those things like,
you know,
you'd get them at the movie theater but
you know they're fucking those slushy.
Slushy,
slushy.
Yeah,
but there were alcohol and there was one
called call a cab because if you drank
it you need to call a cab.
It was like five drinks in one drank like
five drinks worth of alcohol in one of
these fucking things and
you would drink it and it,
you didn't know what you were
drinking because it was so sweet,
like as you were drinking and it didn't
feel like that is a slight alcohol taste
to it,
but good law you but make some fucking
poor decisions after that shit.
And when I was younger,
you just get up,
you'd be in another town,
you're like,
Yo,
we in Atlanta,
we yo,
let's,
let's wild out.
Twice a year I would just
be like on my lights out,
dance shit.
Right.
It's time to do the lights out.
Dance.
That's when you call blacking out.
Sean Merriman played for the charges.
He was doing the crazy like
lights out dance and I was like,
Yo,
I'm about to do the lights out dance.
But I had the chill man after that.
I was like,
I'm too old for this shit.
Very,
very bad for the liver.
Yeah,
that's the,
you gotta get out of hand.
Randall's gotta go.
Wouldn't let them out.
Okay.
Thanks so much.
Thanks Randall.
Man.
Appreciate it man.
I gotta pick up my daughter.
Keep it where it sir.
I'll talk.
I'll talk you soon.
Thanks so much.
That should be on the show of course.
And good luck man.
Good luck with all that
North Korea shit to son now.
He's the best dude for real.
The fucking hung out with
them before the show.
He's a good dude.
Yeah.
That's a crazy position to be in,
man.
To play a dictator that gets banned
that Sony is so scared of it.
They pull it out of the movie theater.
Yeah.
I have so much respect for him because
you meet a lot of people who they'll do
anything for a role.
He's like,
he was trying to like give
his roll back and be like,
I don't think I'm the one for this.
That's amazing.
I was like,
I've never seen honor like this
from anybody in this industry.
So I mean he's,
he's for real.
Yeah.
That's amazing that he made that decision.
Well the,
it's amazing that the movie freaked
them out less than the show.
Yeah.
You know,
one of them was just social pressure or
social responsibility and the other one
being like,
look,
you're a real legitimate threat
where Sony's hiring arm guards.
Yeah.
And it seems like he
freaked out about that less.
Yeah.
It's his,
it was,
for him it was more morals and
values and like representing,
he used to be like an
Asian studies professor.
Really?
Yeah.
There's kids.
Like I'll put up a photo of him
on Instagram and they're like,
Yo,
that's,
that's Randall Park.
He was my professor or my
graduate assistant or whatever.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Well,
he seems like a very educated,
measured sort of a dude.
Real smart.
That's a wild,
wild thing,
man.
To be a part of like one of the most
controversial movies and all of history.
I mean,
if you think about like Hollywood movies,
probably the most controversial,
it's right up there with
passion of the Christ.
Do you remember passion of the Christ?
That while there was that
one and there was the other,
the other one,
um,
before passion of the
Christ Willem Defoe played,
he played Jesus in a much
more controversial film
a long fucking time ago.
I don't remember that one.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
I don't remember the name of it,
but people were mad as fuck because I
think he had like a sexual relationship
with Mary and the movie or something
like that and people last temptation of
Christ.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
People thought it was
blast from this and the,
but it's still,
the thing about Christians is,
man,
you could piss them off and they'll
fucking angry and you get a few death
threats,
but very,
you know,
it's not like someone drawing Muhammad
like this Charlie Hebdo thing.
Like that's the most fucked up of all
the religions to to pick on pick on the
Muslims and they do dark shit.
You start to see a pattern though,
right?
It's like people,
whether it's France or America,
people in like a position of
power feel like they're entitled,
right?
We talked about entitlement.
They feel entitled,
like I have to be able to make fun of
everybody and it's sometimes it's just is
it worth it?
Well,
they think that you got
to change the culture.
That what I think a lot of people think
that it's almost a responsibility to
take those risks because
at the end of the day,
anybody that is angry to the point where
they want to kill someone for satire is
in the wrong and you have to protect
it is you have to protect free speech.
And the only way to protect free speech,
like Sam Harris felt that everyone
should have like unilaterally across the
board,
like every magazine,
every newspaper should
have published all those,
those images.
That's the only way they could
ever protect free speech.
How do you feel?
Well,
I'm not a publisher so I don't,
I see Sam's point,
but I also see the point of people that
don't want to publish it because they
don't want to risk their lives for
something that they feel like is a story
they're reporting on.
They don't feel like it's
their responsibility because
they didn't create those
cartoons,
but they feel like this is a
story they're reporting on.
They can report on that story
without putting them in danger.
This is not like the first time someone's
been killed for making a drawing about
Muhammad.
I mean there's like,
there was some credible threats against
the south park guys after they did
those,
uh,
episodes of South Park where they had
Muhammad in like a guy like was in a teddy
bear outfit and then they
put them inside a truck.
He was talking from inside a truck and
they still were getting like credible
threats.
Like people are saying that
we're going to kill him.
I absolutely believe in
everybody's freedom of speech
to say whatever it is you
want to say.
Like you have to have that right.
But you'll also have to know
there's going to be repercussions.
You can't expect and you
have to calculate it.
Right?
Cause it's also,
do you have to like,
did we have to make the interview?
Did that movie half to get made?
I didn't see it.
So I can't say if I saw it and it
was as funny as like team America,
I would say.
Yeah,
I love team America.
You know,
I don't even think North
Korea's mad about team man.
So I fucking love team America.
But that's why the South Park dudes,
I loved them because they have a purpose
and there's something they're really
saying and it's like
everybody can be in on it.
In a way.
The interview is not nuance like that.
Randall does a really good job for,
I'd say two thirds of the
movie humanizing Kim Jong On.
But then of course like the writing
takes a dive and it just is like,
okay,
here's everything we expected
to see in this movie.
They had a wrap it up,
probably wrapped it up Hollywood proper.
And you know,
it's for people who are in oppressed
countries or an oppressed ideology,
it's why continue to poke them.
You know,
they're gonna respond badly.
You kind of have a responsibility to like,
people just don't fucking poke that dog.
And if you're going to poke that dog,
you got to have a real solid,
legitimate point to what you're doing.
Yeah.
There has to be a positive social
benefit to like what's going on here.
It's not just to like create a stunt to
flex the muscle of freedom of speech.
Yeah.
There's like deep responsibilities that
you have when you taco any like Railey
super controversial.
This is some deep responsibilities.
Yeah.
And that's one of one of the deepest,
right?
Yeah.
Just even me and you,
I probably have the legal right to
say whatever the fuck I want to say,
but like,
why would I say that to you?
I respect you.
Do you know what I mean?
You know,
we do it in our daily lives,
you know?
I mean,
I can see if they,
I don't know,
the Charlie Hebdo thing.
It's strange because what,
what it was really
fascinating to me was not,
not necessarily,
I mean it was horrible what had happened.
It wasn't necessarily surprising,
but what was surprising to me was
like super progressive people who were
criticizing the,
the magazine saying that this is in
response for racist cartoons and they were
almost justifying it in the way they
were saying they weren't justifying it,
but by focusing on what they felt
was racist cartoons instead of like,
Hey,
well so what,
you don't assassins stormed a magazine
and shot people and you would get a
grocery store.
Yeah.
You guys are looking for Social Brownie
points by trying to be like the most
progressive sensitive,
non racist people alive.
Like it's like it's,
it's,
there's only one response.
The response is you should never
kill someone for drawing something.
Absolutely.
My,
you know,
I think what the articles is,
I fully agree with you.
There's,
there's no justification for any
of this radical fucking stuff.
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
I don't even connect it to Islam.
I think it's a cover and it
has nothing to do with Islam.
It is.
These are just people
on their own doing wild,
crazy,
aborad behavior.
My thing is,
is as the rational
people in the situation,
as irrational people in a relationship
to these radical movements,
it's just why inside it,
it's not worth it.
You know,
like we have to be better.
Right?
But when does it end?
I mean,
how do you stop that sort of behavior?
Do you kill everybody
who thinks like that?
What do you do?
I mean,
how do you,
when joining Isis and people keep
joining al Qaeda and you know,
there's a lot of those vice I think did
something called like children of the
drones and talked about how I think me,
me and Shane Talk to you about
it last time we were here,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
people whose families have
been killed by drones,
they'll sign up.
Of course,
they'll go do that.
And you would do,
and I would too,
if you were in that land and your,
your,
your family got killed by some fucking
robot shooting missiles out of the sky.
And they killed the wrong people,
which happens more often than not.
Yeah.
They're way more unsuccessful
than they are successful.
And they think about it this way,
Joe,
like their lives just don't
count like our lives matter.
You know,
like this happened in Paris.
It was terrible.
This terrible tragedy.
There's no justification for any of this.
But then it's,
you know,
what's going on with Boko Haram.
Those lives aren't worth as
much as the ones in Paris,
at least in the eyes of
the press and in the eyes,
the aid and because of Somalis
that were killed and their black.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
those are,
those are some of the factors.
I think there's even more.
But even with drones,
it's like we accept that
innocent people get killed.
If this was in America,
I mean,
we wouldn't accept this is it?
It's cops.
Imagine if cops were using drones,
we wouldn't fucking accept that.
Yeah.
It's Nigeria actually.
Yeah,
I was wrong.
But the,
uh,
I dunno man.
This is the world today,
the climate of the world today.
It's so disturbing.
It's so disturbing that we would think
it's okay to engage in a practice where
the great majority of the people that
get killed by that practice or innocence,
which is what drones are.
Yeah.
And also the thing for me is just like,
I definitely,
I definitely fully agree with you that
there is never a reason to kill anyone
over a satirical article picture,
whatever.
But the fact of the matter is it's like
do we want to save lives or do we want
to make a statement about free speech?
Yeah.
I think it's about saving lives.
I think it's about doing the right thing
and saying these people feel oppressed.
We've killed,
you know,
who knows why they're joining Isis,
who knows why they're joining al Qaeda,
but we need to go the extra mile
and figure out why they're mad,
address these things and not just like
sit on our high horse because they're mad
and they probably have some reason for it.
And whether it's rational or not,
let's diffuse it instead of inciting it.
Like,
that's my opinion is that we're not wrong.
But like let's solve the problem.
And the problem is once you
have someone whose child,
who's the child of someone
who was killed by drones,
or your children were killed
by drones and you become,
you know,
this sort of,
uh,
a radical fundamentalist,
it's,
you can't turn that around.
Like how you,
there's no eye for an eye
there and it's just like they,
you've created something that almost
has to go through generations and
generations in order to calm down and,
and there's no way to have
any sort of immediate fix.
And everybody wants an immediate fix.
You want an immediate fix?
No,
man,
this is going to take a hundreds of years.
And imagine even if you weren't killed
by drones or you're just a kid in Iraq or
Afghanistan and you've seen your entire
neighborhood blown up and you're born
into this life,
you have no choice.
You have nowhere to go,
you have no opportunity,
there's no hope.
And then the one thing
you have is religion.
This,
these people writing these
cartoons making funny you like,
what else do you have?
You know,
we're really kicking people who are,
who have nothing.
And when you poke people who have nothing,
not in a,
it's not reasonable,
but bad things are gonna happen.
And that's what fuels the sort of crazy
conspiracy theories about the military
industrial complex being the
sort of perpetual war machine,
like create enemies like that.
That's the way to create enemies,
destroy areas,
uh,
kill a million innocent people
in Iraq.
That's the,
the number that I've heard.
I mean,
I don't know what the did,
somewhere between several hundred thousand
and a million innocent people have
died as a direct result
of our actions in Iraq.
We just as a number alone man,
that's almost ensuring there's going
to be some sort of a fucking military
conflict over there for a long time.
And the people that are alive today that
are involved in selling arms and the
military industrial complex,
they're going to profit off of
that action for a long time.
And what do we have against these people?
You don't have anything against them.
Don't have anything against them.
How could you know?
I were there like no idea.
And we're there for false
pretenses for both places,
whether it's Afghanistan or Iraq.
The idea behind it was a lie,
especially Iraq.
I mean the idea that,
you know,
the one thing is like,
hey,
you know,
we got rid of a dictator.
Yeah,
we definitely did.
He's a piece of shit,
no doubt about it.
But as a piece of shit,
we propped up,
we put them into place in the first place.
We helped him out and now what's better?
What's better?
Is that better than Isis?
I mean,
we divided that country.
Yeah.
You know,
we divided that country
and then Palestine,
all the countries had
something to do with that.
And,
and then we look at Iraq and people,
even the cynical ones are like,
we're there for oil.
But look at oil prices now
with fracking and natural gas.
Now the oil price has dropped.
And like,
so now why are we still fighting
people while still money?
You know?
Even though this not as much money,
there's still a shitload of oil.
Yeah.
Like I'm against fracking.
But if it can create Middle East peace,
like maybe I'm for fracking,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm definitely against fracking,
but it's just like we
can't win with anything.
Then he,
yeah.
That's,
uh,
people are gross.
Yeah.
And you know,
anyways,
yeah.
And,
and the,
they say the world temperature was the
hottest year ever on records and they
kept,
and they said that by 2025,
it's going to greenhouse gases.
The temperature of the earth
will be irreversible and like,
who knows if that's true,
but I mean,
I feel like we should just
start to work on an owl,
you know.
Well,
do,
they could start to work on it now,
but I think the real issue
is once this cycle has been,
it has begun.
It's almost impossible turnaround.
It's kind of got to play out.
I had this guy,
Randall Carlson on my podcast and
he's going to be on again soon,
um,
and pull that shit up February 2nd.
He'll be back again.
And he's a fascinating guy and he's
an expert on cataclysmic events and,
um,
and,
and global warming,
he said is far preferable
to global cooling.
He's like everybody that's
worried about global warming,
all the great periods in
history as far as advancement,
as far as like a innovation civilization.
They all have followed,
grow global warming,
global cooling on the other hand.
And these were all natural cycles
before we started inventing machines and
carbon emissions and all that shit.
But the global cooling,
he said,
I,
sage is terrible.
Yeah.
I mean,
we could debate this forever,
but the thing is,
is this is an artificial warming.
Well,
it's artificially accelerated.
The cycle has always been,
there's a natural cycle that you could
track that's always existed of warming
and cooling and uncontrollable,
like the ice age that
wasn't caused by man,
you know,
and the ice age.
The ending of the ice age
also wasn't caused by man.
They believe it was caused by Asteroidal
impacts around 12,000 years ago.
But this is something that
Randall's an expert in.
I mean,
he had,
he had these charts and graphs
and showed us all these,
uh,
these photographic pieces of evidence
of global warming's a good thing.
He doesn't,
well,
he,
you know,
everyone's like,
the debate is settled.
He's like,
the debate hasn't even begun.
Like it hasn't even been gone,
but he's saying this,
this is not,
it's,
look,
it's definitely not good.
Pollutants aren't good particulates or
what he's really worried about more than
the warming.
He's worried about what we're doing
to the air and places where they're,
they're burning coal.
Like if you look at China and these
cities that are almost unoccupied bubble
like you,
you,
people can't live there.
They're walking around with the
fucking masks on their face everywhere.
The Sky is perpetually dark gray.
He said,
that's particulates.
that's what we should really,
really be concerned with pollutants,
what we're doing to the ocean.
But he's like,
global warming is a bad thing,
but it's not nearly as
bad as the alternative.
He says.
Interesting.
Global Cooling is terrifying.
I got to listen to that one.
Ooh.
He scared the fuck out of me.
Yeah.
Well,
he also scared the fuck on me because
he was explaining all the verifiable
instances of asteroidal
impacts throughout history,
verifiable where they've asteroids
have hit or comments of hit,
things have hit the earth and just fucked
everything sideways and this is what
they teach.
They tie this into these ancient
structures that are totally unexplained.
Like there's some ancient structures from
pre 10,000 years ago that they didn't
even know people could
build these kinds of things.
Back then they thought the 10,000 years
ago was like people were hunters and
gatherers.
So they've tried to explain
a lot of these structures,
especially cause they're
made out of stone.
They've tried to explain
them by saying no,
they were built,
you know,
much sooner by you know,
modern people and they just
forgot how they built them.
And they were built like 2000
years ago or something like that.
But they have,
there's,
since they've discovered some structures
that they have verified that are twelve
thousand fourteen thousand years old,
like there's some stuff in Turkey that
they found this place called Gold Beckley
Tempe.
They found for sure 12,000 years old,
huge stone columns with three d
reliefs of animals on them and shit.
All really sophisticated stuff for hunters
and gatherers at the time that we're
supposed to be wearing animal
skins and thrown pointy sticks.
It fucking moving creatures,
you know,
so the,
the this Guy Randall
Carlson points to all these,
um,
these instances of core samples where
they find the stuff called nuclear glass
that only exists on nuclear blast
test sites and we're asteroids hit,
it's all over Europe and
Asia at around 12,000 years.
And the core samples.
Wow.
Yeah.
So it was verifiable evidence.
And this is not just him.
There's also these all,
all these other geologists that have found
these micro diamonds that only exists
from massive impact craters,
massive impacts,
just huge,
powerful,
you know,
events.
And they,
so they think that somewhere around
12,000 years ago we were just hit,
you know,
and that happens.
He said it,
it's not,
it's not whether or not
it's going to happen again.
It's when is it gonna happen again?
And you never know.
You never know when things come behind
the sun and we can't even see them until
it's too late because the sun,
the gravity of his son Ben Space and time,
because it's so immense that you literally
can't see them when they're headed
your way.
They're headed your way,
but we can't view them.
So there's things that pass near us
that we didn't see until it's like,
oh Jesus.
You know,
it's really too short fat.
It's really too short.
And even if you don't get
hit by an asteroid like,
dude,
I'm 47 I'm halfway dead looking good,
Joe.
Thank you very much.
But there's no getting around that.
Even if you stay looking good,
what are you gotta look?
Look,
look,
I met Cindy Crawford.
I think she's like 51
or something like that.
So bad.
Still
smoke is still bad.
Oh,
well you know some girls,
they hit that ball hard,
but this bitch has been
preparing for that wall.
She's got fucking rubber shoes.
She puts her feet up.
She's bouncing back.
I don't know what she's doing,
but whatever she's doing,
she should write books and give seminars.
Yeah.
She broke through that wall.
She definitely,
she's doing something.
She's beautiful.
I mean,
not just beautiful for 50 she's beautiful.
Oh yeah.
So you know,
but that doesn't matter.
She's going to die too.
They all die.
Everybody dies.
So whether you get hit by an asteroid
or global cooling or global warming or,
but the reality is civilization
itself might not exist if we get hit.
That's why all the other
shit we're talking about.
People who are like,
they treat it like life
and death and it just like,
like,
come on man.
It's perspective.
Nothing's worth it.
It's all perspective in his life and
death for them because their life is dog
shit.
Know what I'm saying?
If your life is amazing,
it's not life and death.
If somebody draws a cartoon
of your fucking leader.
But even when I was broke,
just selling Dune,
whatever,
like fucking around like life
was still dope is mad font.
Well,
you're a fun dude.
You've got a great personality,
which is why you're,
you should be some sort of an
entertainer in the first place.
You know you in Joe Peshy
we may make this happen.
You want to be the narrow,
you won't be ace.
Nah,
come on.
So I'm not interested.
You don't want to run the Tan Jews.
I think I do too much as it is.
Um,
it's too confusing already being a
podcast or slash cage fighting commentator
slash standup comedian.
That shit is all too confusing.
Your UFC,
you kill it on UFC though.
That shit is great man.
I'm not even a big UFC fan but just cause
like when it's on at the bar or if my
friends are watching,
it's,
it's fucking dope to see
you on that shit man.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
I enjoy doing it.
It's fun.
It's crazy how the,
the athletes,
the level of athletes,
it's just fucking through the roof.
Now you're getting these
John Jones types characters,
Anthony Johnson type characters such
as the high level athletes now that
probably would have been planned other
professional sports like baseball or
basketball or something like that and
now they're fighting and MMA and you're
seeing just,
whew.
Just some high level shit.
Gladiators.
Shit.
I,
I could never imagine fighting
any of those dudes too.
So Shit,
you gotta want to do that and only that,
that's gotta be what you want to do.
There's the people that,
like David was on the podcast once David
showed and he was talking to you about,
uh,
you know,
wanted to have an MMA fight.
I'm like,
don't do it.
He's like,
I just want to do it just to say I did it.
Like,
don't,
you're going to fight somebody.
You were fight someone who lives
for it and you can't do that.
You know your fight some dude and he'll
head kick you and you'll be depressed
for the rest of your life.
Yeah.
Chose so fucking talented.
And he really can do 99% of
everything he wants to do.
But UFC is in that 1%.
It's like chill.
No matter how talented you are,
you will get fucked up.
Well,
I mean,
if he dedicated his whole life to it,
I mean from the time he was like 15 on
Twitter's training him like a fucking
broke his rib critters idea
of being as personal trainers,
like kicking him in the stomach
and it's like take it Dave.
Did they do that?
Yeah,
man in the stomach.
He,
he broke his ribs somehow training him
and then I remember asking her like,
what's he doing?
He's like,
oh,
I've got Dave like
running down the street,
man.
We just wanted it on the street.
He quit.
It's going to break Cho.
But it's perfect for Joe.
Like to have a guy like
clear no critters the best.
So it was hilarious.
All that shit that went down
with him while they were,
you know,
people were decided.
There was the same thing that
we were talking about earlier.
The social justice warriors attacked
him because of the story that he told on
his podcast.
But if you know,
Dave,
he's got this flair for entertainment
where exaggerates the truth and you know,
there's no one coming forward
to say that he raped them.
You know,
this is not like,
this is like he's bullshitting.
Like it's half bullshitting for fun for,
for theater,
for excitement.
Dude is this these days man,
you never know what people are just
needing to get upset instead
of actually getting upset,
they're waiting to get upset.
And also people have one
perspective only they,
oh,
I watched this.
Here's a perfect example.
I was online today and I was,
I was following this abortion
debate between these two people.
And uh,
it was the most bizarre thing ever
where someone was talking about at what,
at what age does the
fetus becomes a person?
And the,
the argument like watching both sides
go back and forth and it wasn't even,
this wasn't even like a right
wing versus left wing side.
Yeah.
It was like someone who is like an
objective rationalist who was debating
someone who's a hardcore left winger who
was also like one of these like Super
White Knights defending women.
You know.
And one of the arguments was it was so
hilarious that it's a woman's right to
choose.
I have no business saying what a woman
should or shouldn't do with her body,
which is universally like,
I agree with that as well.
But what they were saying was
this is where it got really crazy.
No person has the right to exist in
another person's body without permission.
So we're,
they were saying the argument was that
a baby doesn't have the right to use a
woman's body without her permission.
I was like,
this is fucking crazy,
baby cannot use a woman's body.
You were,
they were there.
So pro woman,
so pro,
right?
Like you were talking about like nine
months in like at what point the real
debate was,
and this is,
I think he's a real debate and this is
again coming from me who's pro choice.
There's a real debate as to when is
that a person and to say that it's not a
debate,
it's fucking horseshit to say that it's
not a debate that a woman who gives
birth tomorrow kills the
baby today and it's her.
It's her prerogative.
Like,
okay,
really like at what?
At what time?
Is this creepy?
Is it,
what time is this a born behavior when
someone has a living being inside their
body was not a living,
being told to born well was really like,
come on man.
There's some you,
you have to have some flexibility to
your perception because this is a strange
and very unusual situation
where you're all,
you can terminate a life.
And when I think you can terminate a line,
I mean the,
the,
the image that they were showing was a,
um,
a three day old embryo
and the head of a pin.
So we started this conversation,
which just looks like a few cells,
but when it's a fucking baby with an
umbilical cord in a heartbeat and eyes and
its fingers are moving like,
whoa.
Yeah,
to pretend that's just the new person
has a right to use a woman's body without
her permission.
Like,
Oh really?
You're,
you're absolutely right that there is a
debate that that is being had constantly
at what point something
becomes a human being.
Because there are people,
I mean obviously it's a human
being once it comes out.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not a black and white issue.
It's just not,
it's not,
it's,
it's very,
I'm super pro choice though.
And I just,
as a man,
I feel like women need to decide what
they want to do with their bodies and you
know,
we run so much in this world that for me,
I,
I just don't want to
legislate women's bodies.
Like from my perspective,
no one,
no would suck to be in
a personal situation.
If I had a girl and we were
having a kid eight months in,
she doesn't like me anymore.
Doesn't want to have a kid and wants to,
I mean,
dude right now would be some shit.
Well,
not only that,
like does a woman even have a right to
tell a woman what you can and can't do
for her body?
Obviously a man,
we don't understand.
We don't ever get pregnant.
It's not our concern or it's not a,
it's not up to us to decide,
I should say.
But for a woman,
can a woman tell another woman that she
can't have an abortion at nine months?
I mean like what,
what,
where do we draw this line
question too?
Like where does the government
have an ability to legislate?
Imagine if you were dating someone and
you guys were having a kid and she was
eight months pregnant and
just on a whim decided,
you know what,
I feel like I don't want this baby to
be attendant in my stomach anymore.
Yeah,
it,
his baby does not.
This is a person who does not
have permission to use my body.
Like whoa.
That was the way they phrased it.
That
would really test my intellectual
an end like reasonableness.
Right.
That would really put me to the test.
And that's why when you
think about those situations,
you're like,
king,
we even logically vote on this.
Like you can't really have an opinion
of vote on this until you're in that
situation.
You kind of like needs to be,
well,
the person who was,
who's debating was started insulting.
I'm the super left wing white knight
person started insulting him and calling
him an idiot,
which is always when you know that they're
falling apart in a debate because he
was saying,
okay,
well you were saying before that it's
not a person and now you're saying no
person has the right to use someone's
body without their permission.
So what the fuck is it?
Is it a person?
Are you killing a person that doesn't
have the right to use your body or is it
not a person till it's born?
And then they started
insulting them because they do,
they realize the moral conundrum,
the logical conundrum that they're in,
you know,
it's a fucking real,
like there's no black and white there.
No.
Whether you're a pro choice
or whether you're prolife,
that issue is a,
that is a very bizarre issue.
Yeah.
I mean I'm all about women's rights
in and rights over their body.
That one,
that one,
I don't have the answer,
nor do I want to be part of the
decision making to be honest.
Like I just don't feel like I got
the fucking facts for that one kid.
I don't think anybody has
the facts without one.
Well that's one of those
things about life itself.
If someone wants to abort a baby at eight
months for no real good reason besides
just maybe not wanting to pump it out,
like that's dude,
that's,
that's wow.
But there's a lot of people
that are willing to jump
up and defend women and you
know,
and,
and jump into this,
this position of being the sort of
the,
this defender,
no matter what,
this defender of women's rights
in the world is absolute though.
Like that's the thing I think
people have to believe in.
And also,
yeah,
people hold it as like a badge of honor.
I defend us no matter what
insights they're looking for.
Social Brownie points instead
of objectively discussing
a very bizarre issue.
Well,
it's a very bizarre issue.
Abortions.
Bizarre.
And even you brought up tow,
right?
I love,
we all love Chow and that,
that podcast episode with
the misuse rape story,
Dude,
that put me in a tough spot
that put me in a tough spot,
dude.
You know,
and like I,
people were calling me and
asking me and they're like,
you're an Asian man too.
Do you think this is an
Asian male anchor thing?
And I was like,
Yo,
number one,
this has nothing to do with nothing to
do with what part of the country your
ancestors came from.
That's crazy.
And I'm just like,
but I can't,
I mean,
he's the,
he's the homie and so like I know
who he is and I know his intentions,
but if I didn't know him,
yeah,
I'd be tight at that.
Like that's if you really did that,
like I never asked him,
but I'm like,
if you really did like in my mind,
I'm like,
if you did that,
I don't know if he could be friends,
Homey,
you know?
Well,
what did exactly did he say?
He said that he asked her to touch it.
She started jerking him off and then he
grabbed her head and it has her suck and
she didn't want to.
And then he grabbed her head and
then started mouth fucking her.
Yeah,
that's what he said,
right?
Yeah.
It's a whole,
it's so bizarre.
I get so David Cho,
it's so chill.
It's really the line,
like the motherfucker just
stands on the line and you know,
you look,
if you're a woman and you heard that and
you'd imagine being this poor woman who
was a massage therapist who's being
probably doesn't speak English,
taking this millionaire
guys money and you really,
you know,
you can't,
you shove them out.
That's pretty indefensible dude.
She's already jerking him off.
I mean,
what's up dad?
No,
no,
no.
She didn't want to,
she just tells him want to lose her job.
I'd like,
Yo,
I've,
I'm been with women where even like,
I,
I'm so careful with this shit.
You never know.
Like I'll be dating and grow for
a couple of years and it's just,
you know,
no forcible blowjob.
Do you know what I mean?
I just can't,
I can't do it like I,
but I dated a girl who used to like that.
That was her thing.
She to watch porn where guys were like
grabbing the back of a girl's head and
forcing the head on,
on her chair.
And I was like,
why do you like that?
I mean,
if somebody gives me the Asian Joe Pesci
role and I have to force ginger to suck
my Dick,
I'm going to be morally compromised.
I don't do that in my normal life.
Yeah,
but it's a role.
But if you're dating a
girl and that's her thing,
she likes you to grab her head.
I mean,
it's not involuntary.
She wants to do this beforehand.
And she signs the papers when my lawyer,
so that for the next six months I can,
you know,
do this.
And that's what you want.
Sure.
Have you ever seen that
Louis Ck joke about that?
No.
He does it.
He's dating some girl or
hooks up with some girl.
They started making out and he
tries to have sex or she says no,
and then he sees the
next day and she goes,
what happened last night?
And he goes,
what do you mean?
She goes,
well,
why didn't we have sex?
He goes,
well,
I tried,
but you didn't want to.
She goes,
no,
I did.
And he goes,
well,
why?
Why did you say no?
She goes,
why?
I was hoping you would just go for it.
He goes,
what?
You wanted me to rape you on the off
chance that you're into that shit?
No,
she got,
that's the dance.
The shorty that like fucks everybody.
Not only are you fucking women and
women's body image and women's rights,
but now you're fucking dude's
cause now you just taught to do,
to move,
like rubbing your elbow into the boobs.
I mean like now you just,
now you put a really
bad tool in the toolbox.
Yeah.
It's not because the next
time Louis C K gets to that.
Oh it means,
yes,
it's a great bit.
It's a great bit because
any man who dates more than,
you know,
x amount of women,
it's going to come across when you're
going to come across in an aberration,
a very rare person who has were like
this girl that I used to date who wanted
guys to grab her head,
force it on her dick.
Like she wanted a blow me,
but she wanted me to grab it.
She would like,
I dated her for awhile.
She was her shit.
That was what she was into.
She wanted to get on her knees and she
wants you to grab the back of her head
and like face fucker.
I'm so,
I'm funny,
I've been in a situation where
it's like I want to be choked,
right.
Or I want to be smacked or whatever and
like look in the heat of the moment,
the customer is always right.
So I'll do it.
Right.
I'm in the service industry after I'll
always be like,
I'll always,
I'll always be like,
Yo man,
like is something wrong?
Like you okay?
Like what the fuck did your dad do to you?
You know,
and I'm always kind of just like,
Yo this like he can't like,
cause I would never want
to be punched in the face.
You're a guy and I think
there's also a different,
like women,
there are women who have
legitimate rape fantasies.
It's a social structural thing though.
Like if it is it or is it a dude?
One masculine and feminine thing.
Definitely men who want to be raped.
No,
Dang.
Yeah.
Why do you think,
Oh hell no.
Not Jamie,
but I have a friend who
likes getting tied up,
man.
He likes girls to beat him up.
Oh,
that's right.
No,
you're right.
You're right there aren't there are.
He likes being abused at all.
I'm glad you brought that up cause
I was about to chalk it up to like,
we live in a patriarchal society
and we treat them like shit.
And that's must be why they want this.
But you're right,
there are,
there are dudes too.
Yeah,
there's,
there's people that it's not easy to
nail down single spot on the spectrum and
there's no,
I mean there's,
look,
there's men who wished there were women.
There's women who wished there was men.
There's men who'd like to beat
women as women who like to beat men.
There's men who like to
get beat up by women.
There's a,
there's like,
I think the end of the story is basically
just like sexually people are fucked
and there's no normal,
there's no normal,
there's no new customer's always right.
There's a,
there's a law that they're passing in
California called the Yes means yes law.
And the idea is you're
supposed to get verbal consent.
The idea is to curb these
college rape issues,
which are constantly,
and a lot of them,
they think they think there's one way
to mitigate that is to make sure that
people communicate.
Because like sometimes like things are
just happening and women like feel awful
about it afterwards,
but they didn't know how to
stop it when it was going on.
So the idea being that a guy has
to say every step of the way,
can I take your clothes off?
Can I put my finger in you?
Can I,
you know,
put my dick inside you.
Can I do this?
Can I do that?
And there's like a video that accompanies
it called consent is sexy and it's
hilarious.
It's weird campaign where you get this
hipster looking dude with a goofy fucking
beard and he just looks like a kind of
a bitch and he's with this really hot
girl and he's like,
can I kiss you?
Yes.
And the kisses,
it was just like ordering,
take your shirt off.
Sandwich.
Not yet.
Yes.
Francina yes.
Olives.
Like that's fucking weird.
And she asks him,
can I touch your leg?
He's like,
yeah.
It's like,
oh,
let's just get this straight.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
Okay.
You got the green light honey?
Yeah.
He's telling me when I can
stick it in the fucking,
the easy pass.
Just like,
yeah,
put that shit on her forehead.
It's like a Turkey tester.
See that point?
So that's sticking out.
Go like that's,
yeah,
it's just like this.
You're at the casino buffet.
Just bring your plate,
fucking eat everything.
I'm going to put a fucking of a thing
over your neck on a lanyard while you're
wearing that.
You could do whatever you want.
Touch me any way you want.
You've got a green light,
but you know like a girl saying,
can I touch your leg?
And the kind of yes,
like get the fuck out of here.
What guys that were said,
I didn't give you
permission to touch my leg.
Yes.
Museum shows during judgment.
It also the asshole in me.
Like I would have more fun,
like just fuck fucking with them.
Then actually fucking them.
Like if they were like,
can I touch your leg and be like,
just this area here.
You know,
only an inch above Miami.
Don't disrespect your thigh.
Five inches below my taint,
three and above the knee.
You're safe.
You touch anything else?
I'll fucking cut.
Well there was a guy who
was debating it and he was,
well,
he was arguing with this yes means yes
thing and he had this really important
point.
He said there was a moment that
happened to me when I was in college.
He goes,
where?
I met this girl,
we were at a bar and I had
a couple of drinks we had.
We'd never talked.
She looked at me,
I looked at her and she raised her
eyebrows and she went like that,
like,
like this come here.
And the guy walked towards her.
She put her hand out,
he grabbed her hand,
he took her into the woman's bathroom,
have fucked her in a stall and he said,
we never talked.
He goes,
it was one of the greatest nights of
my life because I've jerked off like a
hundred times since then.
Thinking about it.
I never talked to her again.
I never,
we never,
we didn't become boyfriend and girlfriend.
I didn't speak to this girl.
We didn't expect,
we didn't exchange words.
It was allowed.
Cub
went into the bathroom with her.
Any,
they fucked,
they fucked.
They didn't even know each other.
And he's like,
this could not happen
with his yes means yes.
Shit.
And it was the greatest night of my life.
I don't mean that he goes,
it was instigated by a
girl like you and me,
the of face,
you know,
and grabbing my hand
and next thing you know,
we're in a bathroom and we're having sex.
You know,
like that kind of Shit does happen
with people and pretty much every girl,
I mean the thing you try to block
it out when were in relationship,
but pretty much every girl
you know is given a bathroom,
blowjob,
you know what I mean?
Sorry guys.
All your wives taking a bath was,
is what it is.
You have to access like boys,
boys like girls,
some boys like boys and girls
like girls who gives a fuck.
It's fine.
And bathrooms are totally fucking
fine places for our comments to come.
Common motherfuckers are warming.
Exactly.
And it's like to legislate.
This shit is just like,
come on man.
It's not the way.
The way is education
more than legislation.
That's the way,
but how do you educate a
kid that's 18 years old?
I grew up at douchebag
parents and he's got,
you know,
some sort of a sociopathic mindset.
It's like how do you educate people
out of that besides psychedelic drugs
besides some total reset of the mind
with Ibogaine Iowasca or DMT or mushrooms
without that and even
that doesn't always work.
There's people that are fucking complete
sociopath that have done all kinds of
psychedelics.
I know people that are
out of their fucking mind,
Eagle maniacs that are like purportedly
psychedelic users and I'm like,
how was that guy was like a delegate.
He doesn't check himself at all.
He's not looking at himself
introspectively at all.
So it doesn't work on everybody,
man.
There's no every,
it's like we were saying the spectrum.
It's just giant.
It's giant.
We are so fucking weird.
Humans are just fucking weird bro.
It was weird and I almost think like
we have to be weird in order to,
in order for this super organism to exist,
the way exists and function,
the way it functions,
and in order for innovation,
culture and
society to exist,
it almost seems like everybody
has to play this very weird,
unique role.
And some people are pretty obvious and
pretty straight forward and cookie cutter
and you're like,
oh,
I see one of these before.
And then other people you meet him,
you're like,
whoa,
this bitch is crazy.
You know?
I want people to be as weird
as they possibly can as
long as it doesn't infringe
on my ability to be weird myself.
Let's say you go,
that's it.
That's like the basis of the social
contract and this is the guy I want you to
be fucking psycho.
Yeah.
The weird thing is like when someone tries
to prevent you from being who you are
because whatever you enjoy offends them,
even if it doesn't hurt anybody or if
your desires like requires somebody else
to be victimized,
like then that's,
that's too weird.
But that's,
that's different.
But as long as no one's being hurt and
everyone is agreeable upon the act,
like it's like gay
marriage or gay sex at all.
Like anybody who's got an issue with
people that are fucking each other.
Like what do you care?
Like what is it about you,
whether it's religion or whether it's,
uh,
you know,
social issues.
What is it about you that
gives a fuck with someone does,
if two chicks want to live with each
other and put on rubber strap ons and plow
each other all day,
why does that freak you out?
Enjoy.
You know,
the big world.
It's not like there's only five people.
Yeah.
You know,
you could do it upstairs from me.
I don't care.
You're whatever.
If you're loud.
Live on those all departments.
That squeaky floors.
I love noise when I'm sleeping.
I need noise.
Yeah.
I have to like turn the TV on,
leave the TV on and shit real.
Yeah.
I don't like,
I don't like quiet when I sleep.
Wow.
That's weird.
Maybe like New York,
like when,
when the garbage truck came a fight.
Like I was like,
fantastic.
Really sleep.
Good noise.
Where do you live in New York?
Uh,
well I,
my,
my apartment my brother has now is in
Fort Greene on a Delphi between decal and
Lafayette.
Is that Brooklyn?
Yeah.
That's when my brother lives there now.
But um,
I don't,
I get to live in New York.
No,
that I live out here now.
Do you really?
Yeah.
How long you been here for?
Seven months.
We got to hang,
we got to hang and we ain't
got to do a regular podcast.
And you're hilarious dude.
I love doing this.
I love you doing it man.
Yeah.
So do you like open the window up
out here to hear the horns and shit?
I leave.
I leave the window,
but I'm like the border
of Malibu Palisades soon.
Super Quiet.
Chill.
Yeah.
I just didn't,
he learned the leave the TV on.
Oh,
that's what he did.
He fall asleep.
That's so weird.
Have you always been like that?
Yeah.
You know,
I think,
cause my mom was always screaming and
yelling and fighting with my pops.
So it's like I went to bed with Connie
Corleone just breaking on the place.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
Well people are adaptable as fuck,
man.
People are like,
some people like they
cannot deal with the city.
They coming to cities start freaking
out and some people they freak out when
they go to the country.
They just don't like it.
And I'm like desensitized.
I'm totally dissed.
I've,
I've seen anything that you could possibly
throw be thrown and just my a maniac.
That's hilarious.
They're still together though.
Yeah,
they're still together.
They still fight all the time.
Wow.
Yeah.
My grandparents fought so hard dude
that I thought that I would never get
married.
I thought I would never
have a relationship.
I my my,
like I had issues with relationships
based on not just my parents,
my mother and father.
My,
my actual father.
I grew up with,
my stepdad was a great guy,
but my actual dad was a
real fucking piece of shit.
Yeah.
And is very violent,
abusive.
And I saw a lot of domestic abuse.
Yeah.
Heard a lot.
But I saw some like dark
shit when I was a little kid.
And then my mom,
my grandma,
my grandparents,
they didn't physically fine,
but they would fucking scream at each
other so hardcore that I would never want
to be in a relationship.
I was like,
fuck this man aiming at each other.
Parents physically fought and I,
I used to always reach for the phone and
call the cops and both of them we'd be
like,
don't do it.
And I was like,
wait,
the one thing you guys can agree
on is for me to not call the cops.
And they'd be like,
go upstairs,
hide your brothers.
And I would just like put my brothers
under the bed and then close the door.
And they were younger than me
cause I was the oldest thing,
what's going on.
And I had no answers for them,
man.
Wow.
I have no answer.
They were younger than you.
So you were the one that had to
make sense of it all to them.
It was rough.
It was rough on my sister was
a year younger than me when my,
uh,
mom and dad had like this
physical altercation that
made my mom move out of the
house.
Yeah.
My Dad smacked the shit on my mother
in front of the kitchen and my little
sister ran and hid and I hid and we were,
we were both freaked out,
but my sister just shut it out.
She doesn't even remember it.
She doesn't talk about it.
I can't forget it because
in my mind it was like,
okay,
now I know that my dad is a shithead.
Like I used to think that like he was
a hero and he was a great guy and you
know,
every body wants to think
their dad is superman.
Yeah.
You know,
when,
when it was undeniable
proof that he wasn't it,
fuck my head up,
you know.
But I only had my little sister,
she was only a year younger than me.
It wasn't like a,
how to like explain everything
that's my youngest brother is good with a,
he's well adjusted.
Me and my other,
my middle brother,
we've never really let it go.
It's like a part of us and I wished that
there was one parent that I could just
be like,
they're the good one
and the other one's bad,
right.
My mom would like throw hot
water at my pops and I'd be like,
what the fuck is going on?
And then,
you know,
he would do his Dame,
I smack or whatever.
And then she tried to punch him and
then he'd hit her and I was just like,
this is WWF in the crib.
I got a friend who
still fights with his wife and his wife
threw a fucking screwdriver at him and
stuck him in the arm.
I get stuck out of his arm
and he fucked her that night.
He goes,
that shit turns me on.
And I go,
what?
And he goes,
one time,
man,
it will,
this is hilarious.
They were watching a
movie together and uh,
she fell asleep at the movie.
So he took his pants down and
it was there watching hundred.
He took
his pants down and put his ass hole
like an inch away from her head.
And he goes and he yelled something.
She woke up and he
farted right in her face.
That's a new move.
That's the cornholio.
Oh man,
that's an easy fucking went crazy.
She punched him in the mouth.
She fucking freaky.
She goes,
he goes,
she fucking made me see stars.
Like she cracked me in
the job and he goes,
I fucking love it.
That shit turns me off.
But that turns you on.
I know,
man.
When I saw this stuff with my parents,
I was just like,
I never want to be in a family like this.
Exactly.
I've always just dated.
Just Nice,
good people.
Yeah.
That's what I like.
I like,
I like people that are nice year.
Sweet.
Yeah.
Want no yelling?
No,
not in the island.
No.
I don't want to yell at my friends.
I don't want anybody yelling at me.
That's the one thing I
looked for people as,
what do you look for when you hire people?
Good.
Trustworthy people.
Good values.
That's it.
You can't,
you can't teach that.
People have it or they don't.
Yeah,
and avoid people that you
can have disputes with.
Like,
maybe it's not them.
Maybe it's how you get along with
them that makes them the way they are,
but whatever the fuck it is,
just take the path of least resistance.
Yeah.
Cause the asteroids are fucking comment
come and even wasn't on the way.
All of the above.
Global warming.
Global Cooling.
Yeah.
This was fun though,
man.
Yeah.
I had a great time.
Fucking going to do it,
my friend more often.
Right around,
dude,
we got to hang.
And when does he show start?
February 4th.
February 4th February
4th fresh off the boat.
Anyone?
You're a bad mother fucker.
Thank you.
Thank you,
sir.
I appreciate,
follow him on Twitter.
It's Mister Eddie won.
Mr Eddie,
Much love my friend at squad.
He's here.
We'll do it more often,
folks.
Yup.
See you soon.
It was so much fun.
The column name?
Yeah.
Okay.
Hm.